Aham. Bem felizes.
Primeira coisa, shopping e pizzaria.
Chegando
>> Coca-Cola.
[Música]
sexu
cor
[Música]
Corvat
சமாசுதா
சாதான்
சரண
[Música]
சชமின
சнமிส
[Música]
சங்க
சரண
தா
[Música]
புத
சன
[Música]
தம்பிதான்
சனமி
[Música]
தாதி
சக
[Música]
சரணமிส
அரஹமா
சம்பத
Então, então, bom dia.
>> Bom dia,
>> pessoal. O tempo tá terminando,
terminando rápido,
então.
Então, eh, nós estamos um pouco,
eh limitados
a quando a gente pensa em entrar nesse
âmbito da energia,
porque,
ah, comparativamente com olhos, ouvidos,
nariz, língua e tato,
energia nem todos vêm.
A gente tem poucas experiências que a
gente localizou isso, localizou aquilo.
Então nós temos esse problema, esse
problema. Por isso que a gente fica
sempre olhando os aspectos de sabedoria
ligados a olhos, ouvidos, nariz, língua
e tato, porque isso a gente vê.
Mas o aspecto de energia ele é muito
importante
porque ele rege o nosso funcionamento.
Por exemplo, o funcionamento do corpo,
ele rege também, ele é uma expressão da
mente.
A mente tem várias formas de de atuar,
né? Ela tem aspectos que ficam ocultos,
que a gente não vê usualmente, né?
porque a gente termina localizando os
aspectos cognitivos, discursivos,
causais, né? Mais os os aspectos
assim aparentes como objetos, né? E nós
também localizamos as ideias que são os
objetos da mente, né?
Mas esse esse aspecto dos objetos da
mente, que são objetos cognitivos,
discursivos, causais, eles também nem
todo mundo fica olhando isso direito,
né? Mas a gente pode ser treinado antes
de terminar vendo.
Por exemplo, quando a gente fala de
karma, nem todos vem, mas eu tô falando
de causalidade. Isso é uma causalidade
complexa.
E existem assim vastas regiões que as
pessoas simplesmente não vão considerar
o carro. Elas pensam que as ações que
elas fazem não tm consequências.
Então tem tradições religiosas que não
incluem o karma. Por exemplo, se vocês
olharem o Antigo Testamento, Antigo
Testamento não inclui o karma.
Aquilo eu acho impactante até os dias de
hoje. Por quê? Porque se vocês olham,
olhem com cuidado com esse olhar, vocês
vão ver e as mensagens são assim: eh,
Deus é de um povo. Então, por exemplo,
quando os judeus cruzaram
o Jordão, aí eles tinham uma mensagem de
Deus. vocês não façam acordo com nenhum
povo, vocês têm que vencer e acabar com
eles.
Se vocês fizerem qualquer acordo, vocês
vão pagar um custo muito elevado,
né? Então isso não é uma linguagem de um
Deus universal, entende? Também não é
uma linguagem de uma ação que não tem
uma consequência cármica.
Ela tem uma consequência cármica. Aí se
conta que houve um povo que se cobriu de
pó e chegou
pros judeus que estavam ainda se
retirando do Egito, procurando uma
terra né?
E eles disseram: "Nós viemos de muito
longe, nós queríamos fazer um convênio
com vocês, assim, um acordo de paz". Aí
os judeus olharam: "Bom, se isso aqui é
de muito longe, não vai nos afetar".
Então eles fizeram. Aí depois veio uma
punição, veio uma punição porque eles
tinham feito e eles também não eram de
muito longe, eles dali mesmo,
né? Então o que que aconteceu? Então,
eh, os judeus eh escravizaram eles.
Então, essas ações, elas são todas no
desconhecimento do aspecto cármico. Eu
considero que esse tipo de ideologia,
ela segue operando hoje,
né? Nós vamos ver as pessoas, elas vão
fazer o que elas bem entenderem, como se
não tivesse consequência nenhuma.
Então, é como se tivesse uma inspiração
que vem de algum lugar muito elevado,
que me empodera e o que eu fizer tá bem,
porque vem dessa região e eu obedeço e
pronto.
Qualquer pessoa alucinada faz isso, né?
Vocês vão olhar as pessoas que estão num
estado psicótico, tão numa crise
esquizofrênica, elas ouvem vozes e elas
fazem coisas como se fossem
predestinadas.
E as consequências vêm rapidamente, né?
De modo geral, as pessoas são
internadas medicadas
e vai começar assim, porque eles começam
a ficar eh um perigo público, um perigo
paraas famílias, perigo para si mesmas,
né? As pessoas olham, acham que aquilo é
horrível. Ainda assim, na visão budista,
todas elas têm a natureza búdica, né? e
a natureza búdica que vai, enfim, surgir
como essa grande abertura que permite
que a pessoa surja de um outro jeito. A
gente já viu isso acontecer muitas
vezes né?
Mas
pode surgir esse desconhecimento do
aspecto causal. Então, eu tô tomando
isso como um exemplo, botando entre
parênteses, porque isso não é o tema. O
tema é assim, a operação da nossa mente,
a gente não reconhece direito mesmo a
sexta consciência, que é essa mente
lógica que tem objetos,
né? Então, entre os objetos da nossa
mente lógica tem a causalidade.
Então, a causalidade a gente pode não
reconhecer.
Eu acho que as crianças têm um pouco de
dificuldade de reconhecer causalidade.
Os adolescentes têm um pouco de
dificuldade, né? Então a gente conversa
com os adolescentes que eu conheço, diz:
"Olha, te organiza melhor assim, se tu
precisar de mim, tu já avisa antes,
vamos combinar tudo". Mas aí quando eu
vejo aí surgem mensagens urgentes para
resolver coisas que estão acontecendo
assim, né? Aí a gente tem que fazer uma
uma magia assim e resolver aquilo, né?
Mas nem sempre acontece. A gente
consegue, nem sempre consegue, né?
Mas, por exemplo, se a gente se organiza
um pouco, entende como é que as coisas
causais vão, mas eventualmente as
pessoas elas não têm paciência para
tratar das coisas causares. Elas não
reconhecem bem, elas têm como que uma um
comportamento mágico, né? Eu eu gosto
desse comportamento mágico porque ele é
uma base, né? As coisas são todas
mágicas, mas dentro de um mundo
condicionado, de um mundo de acordos
entre pessoas, aí surge um processo
causal, surge o espaço, o tempo, tudo
aparece assim.
Então eu acho um desafio,
como por exemplo a Helen, né, que tá num
mundo organizado, com causalidade, ainda
assim tem que manter a mente livre, né?
É assim. Então o processo, ops, é criar
uma, a gente cria uma bolha, que é o
processo mágico, aí dentro da bolha
causal, nada daquilo é um é
completamente real, mas dentro daquele
processo, aquela causalidade opera. Como
tu cria um jogo de tabuleiro que eu não
vou citar o nome, aquilo é, eu não
aguento mais,
aquilo é luminoso, mas dentro, uma vez
estabelecido as regras, ele é tudo
causal. É melhor entender, entende? É
assim.
Então nós estamos com esse processo, mas
isso tudo pertence à mente, a sexta
consciência que vai criando os objetos e
vai operando de modo causal, discursivo.
Aí a linguagem faz sentido, né?
linguagem assim, se você, por exemplo,
você vai jogar hoje, um discurso assim,
né? É melhor levar os tênis, né? É
assim, é melhor levar uniforme, né?
Então, às vezes tem coisas muito
urgentes que tem que acontecer assim, a
pessoa chega na cancha e não levou a a
roupa adequada, né? Assim, então
é melhor a gente se organizar, né? Se a
gente vai pra escola, é melhor ir de
tênis, não vai de chinelo assim, porque
a última hora quando vai pensar que vai
botar o tênis e o tênis não tá no carro.
E aí, como é que faz?
Então isso é causalidade, né? A gente se
organiza dentro das bolhas específicas
assim. Mas aí tem essas outras ações.
Por exemplo, a ação da energia, ela não
é uma ação causal, que é uma das coisas
que nos desespera um pouco, porque nós
estamos focados nos processos causais
que a gente vê mais ou menos. A gente
diz: "Bom, agora eu quero que apareça
energia para estudar, energia para fazer
uma faxina, energia para várias coisas
assim.
Aí como qual é a alavanca que eu puxo
para então produzir isso? Aí não tem
alavanca, pessoal, porque a energia não
vem desse lugar, ela vem de um outro
tipo de ação da mente, né? Mas se o
próprio objeto, que a gente tá chamando
de energia, a gente não consegue ver
direito, só vê mais ou menos assim,
quando a gente tá animado ou tá
desanimado, a gente vê mais ou menos
isso. Porque por vezes a gente quando tá
animado, a gente diz: "Eu tô animado por
causa disso". Quando tá desanimado, a
gente te diz: "E tô desanimado por causa
disso". Então aquilo é reduzido de novo
para um aspecto de causalidade e a gente
não consegue ver o aspecto não causal
disso, né? E aí nós, então a gente
precisa entender essa mente que
atua criando o jogo, por exemplo,
criando o entorno dentro do qual a mente
racional causal discursiva
cognitiva opera,
né? Então esse processo ele é super
importante a gente entender esse outro
âmbito de ação. Esse outro âmbito de
ação a gente já viu mais ou menos que é
o aspecto luminoso da realidade, né? A
gente tá deslizando por dentro disso,
assim, a gente de novo olha e de novo
olha e de novo olha e a gente vai se
esquecendo e vai olhando e vai se
esquecendo. A gente rapidamente
escorrega de novo pra sexta consciência
pensando que todas as ações causais elas
resolvem, né? Então o budismo vajaiana
que tem vários tipos de, por exemplo,
pode ser com deidade, sem deidades,
simplificar. Eh, ele vai, ele é definido
como aquilo que vai atuar com a
consciência do aspecto de luminosidade,
espacialidade
e energia.
Então, nós precisamos desenvolver um
olho que vê isso, né? E aqui a gente tá
olhando um exemplo, outro exemplo, outro
exemplo, a gente esquece também, porque
a gente escorrega rapidamente por
aspecto causal, discursivo, cognitivo,
etc.,
que são aspectos que pertencem ao
sansara. O sansara é o lugar onde nós
não vemos a grande abertura, nem a
luminosidade da nem a ação luminosa da
mente. Também é o lugar onde a energia
ela surge magicamente. Eu não tenho uma
capacidade de dirigir isso, né? Nós
terminamos dirigindo energia através da
disciplina. É como se a gente forçasse
assim energia e a gente nunca consegue
fazer aquilo direito. E se a pessoa
consegue forçar a energia, arrumar, ela
vai adoecer também tem esse problema,
porque ela vai ficar também muito
rígida. Ela vai ficar com vários
problemas assim, né?
Então, nós precisamos cruzar essa essa
essa limitação e entender a ação da
mente, sendo que essa compreensão da
ação da mente, ela não é alguma coisa
religiosa, vocês entendem? Isso é alguma
coisa que eu vejo operando.
Eu acho que esse campo é um campo que
falta, por exemplo, é como se os
cientistas fossem até a sexta
consciência, eles tivessem dificuldade
de entender esse outro pedaço. Então, o
diálogo com a ciência, ele é um diálogo
onde esse outro aspecto ele precisa ser
visto, ser entendido, sem que aquilo
pareça alguma coisa mística que brota de
um lugar, de um paraíso alto, de alguma
coisa onde tem ETS que vão comandar
aquilo, né? Mas essa linguagem ela vai
ela vai dar um sentido lógico, claro,
uma visão assim eh muito
lúcida, que nos permite ver o quê? Ver
os deuses,
as deidades e ver não sei quanta coisa
mais. Por quê? Porque eu vou começar a
nomear esses deuses, essas deidades,
essas mandalas, esses lugares como os
lugares que comanda a nossa energia.
Porque quando nós começamos a ver
energia, por exemplo, se vocês
caminharem com cuidado, como a gente
estava olhando ontem, por dentro de um
bosque
e vocês já vem energia, vocês vão vão
ver as presenças dos seres, nós vamos
dizer assim. Por quê? Porque a nossa
energia começa a responder. Então a
gente se aproxima de um lugar, energia
de um tipo. Eu termino dizendo, bom,
aqui tem uma deidade. Quando eu chego
aqui, eu tenho as bênçãos dessa deidade.
É assim, sendo que essas deidades são
todas na visão budista são chamadas de
deidades mundanas. Elas não são a
áriatara, não são tirenzig, não são
Contuzo, nem prag na parameta. Elas são
deidades mundanas porque elas movem as
nossas sensações,
elas podem nos ajudar, elas podem até
nos curar.
Então, a gente pode ir para alguns
lugares, a gente sente aquilo, captura
aquilo, a nossa a nossa experiência
melhora, é um outro tipo de ação.
Nós vamos eh também entender nesse
âmbito do Vajarena, nós vamos entender a
ação que brota desde a grande abertura,
que é o aspecto central dos
ensinamentos.
Mas como a gente tá na sexta consciência
ou perdão, nas seis primeiras
consciências
e não temos clareza, a gente não
consegue entender bem isso. Porque para
entender a ação desde a grande abertura,
nós precisamos reconhecer
como que as bolhas de realidade são
criadas luminosamente, como que a
energia opera por dentro disso. E aí nós
vamos reconhecer que esse processo ele
vem como uma manifestação direta da
grande abertura.
Aí eu vou descobrir essa essa mente que
não é pessoal,
que inicialmente eu penso que ela é
pessoal. Eu sinto como se fosse pessoal,
mas eu logo vou perceber que ela não tem
conteúdo. Então se ela não tem conteúdo,
eu não consigo encontrar o carimbo da
minha família ali dentro. o carimbo do
meu nome.
E eu vejo que todos os seres estão
operando a partir disso e surge com as
suas bolhas, depois surge com as suas
energias e aí eles operam logicamente ou
cognitivamente
dentro dos processos das bolhas já
delimitadas. Nós vemos isso por todos os
lados. Aí nos ensinamentos nós vamos
ver, os mestres vão dizer que há Budas
em cada milímetro cúbico, em cada
partícula, em cada lugar, que é a
descrição
de do Buda primordial na mandala do
lótus, olhando todos os seres e vendo
esse aspecto. Então, quando isso surge,
nós vamos reconhecer todos os seres como
ondas do mesmo mar. E o mar é a grande
abertura.
Então nós temos as ondas surgem,
excessam e elas nunca vão ter vitórias,
nunca vão conseguir alguma coisa final,
porque elas são construções da sexta com
sexta para baixo. Elas são construções
que surgem dentro de bolhas e aparecem
por um tempo, mas como elas são ondas de
um mesmo mar, elas seguem sendo o mesmo
mar. Então elas não têm como, não tem um
final.
Se vocês olharem,
a as ondas sempre foram o grande mar,
elas nunca foram outra coisa, mas quando
as identidades surgem, elas e nós nós
operamos com ela a partir da forma da
onda. A forma da onda tem um jogo
próprio. Então nós estamos imersos nas
formas das ondas. A gente pode pensar,
bom, a onda foi criada, então ela tá
ali, mas a onda muda momento a momento.
Então nós também mudamos momento a
momento. Assim, a gente pensa, bom, eu
vivo momento a momento e ao final eu
bato contra a praia e dissolvo. E aí,
para onde é que eu vou? Não vou para
lugar nenhum
assim porque
não nós não saímos do grande mar e não
voltamos pro grande mar porque nós
estamos no grande mar sempre, né? Então
esse aspecto também essa compreensão de
que não há nada a ser feito, porque nós
estamos dentro do grande mar e as formas
vão mudando e a praia chega e tudo
desaparece. A nossa onda terminou, mas
estão vindo outras ondas infinitamente,
né? Esse aspecto ele é a base daquilo
que nós vamos chamar da natural
perfeição. Por quê? Porque tudo isso tem
é uma manifestação luminosa, incessante,
que se propaga sem nenhuma ah restrição,
sem nenhum obstáculo. Mas dentro do jogo
das ondas tem umas ondas reclamando das
outras. Você tá aqui mudando, eu não
consigo um do lado direito perto de você
que você é isso, você é aquilo. Você é
muito pequeno, muito grande, muito
igual, muito junto de mim e você tá não
sei bem o quê, né? Mas eu sei, você vai
bater contra a praia, você tá liquidada.
E a outra responde: "Você também, mas
vai ser depois.
Aquilo não tem fim, pessoal". Então nós
estamos nesse nesse processo,
mas como as ondas geram um pouco de
ansiedade, por incrível que pareça,
surgem os budas desde esse lugar muito
amplo e diz: "Pobre ondas
assim, vamos socorrer, vamos dar mão
para elas, né?" Aí eles mudam lá, "Não,
vamos até a praia juntos".
É assim, não se sinta, relaxe, vai dar
certo. Sempre dá certo. Bateu contra a
praia sempre dá certo.
Sim. Aí nós estamos indo, nós estamos
nesse, nesse processo, pessoal. É assim,
né? Então aqui a gente vai olhar um
pouco, vamos tentar olhar
isso aqui, uma introdução para para
explicar porque que o aspecto, vamos
dizer, da energia e da luminosidade, por
exemplo, mas agora especificamente
energia, que é o tema aqui, é um é um
processo que a gente não consegue entrar
muito com a mente racional, discursiva,
cognitiva, porque porque os próprios
objetos que a gente tá se referindo, a
gente não aprendeu a olhar direito,
então a gente não consegue. É como se
tivessem
peças no jogo que tu não vê direito.
Então esse é o ponto de energia. Nós não
temos muita familiaridade. A gente tem
familiaridade com objetos de olhos,
ouvidos, nariz, língua e tato. Então
fica mais fácil de eu revelar o aspecto
delusivo deles, mas o aspecto de energia
eles não são. Então, de modo geral, esse
processo quando ele a pessoa não tem uma
intuição que venha de uma outra vida,
o processo tem que ser de baixo para
cima e não de cima para baixo. Porque se
tu explicar de cima para baixo, a pessoa
não vê os objetos, aí tu não tem o que
dizer, né? Então o processo de baixo
para cima é como os ensinamentos
do Alejandro, aluno do Tenzinho
Mangueal, né? como os próprios
ensinamentos do do Tenzinho Anguiolchet,
né, que felizmente é amigo da nossa
sangra, e outros mestres também que vão
trazendo esses ensinamentos,
como agora o Dr. Nida também que tá
chegando aqui no Brasil esse ano, teve
aí, espero que no ano que vem ele também
nos visite lá em Sucavate, né?
Mas o que que eles vão propor? Eles vão
propor uma familiarização com o aspecto
de energia.
Eles começam com exercícios simples
assim. Eu diria que esses exercícios
vocês todos podem fazer ou todo mundo já
fez um pouco ligado a diferentes outras
tradições assim, né?
Mas um dos exercícios,
uma das tradições é a tradição da dos
vários tipos de yoga e pranaiana, né?
Então, se a gente desenvolver um pouco
essa familiaridade,
a gente já tem um pouco mais de
de capacidade de sentir, de ver,
portanto, esses aspectos e poder
raciocinar a partir disso.
Então, tem exercícios simples que eu
acho super poderosos e que já nos
permite eh eh progressivamente
eh
desenvolver uma familiaridade.
Então, por exemplo, o Dr. Nida, ele vai
desenvolver
são muitos diferentes exercícios. Por
exemplo, se vocês vão querer trabalhar
os músculos, aí tem máquinas de todo
tipo, tem calestemia, tem rato yoga, tem
muitos jeitos que tu pode trabalhar os
músculos. Então, quando a gente vai
trabalhar de um jeito, a gente tá não tá
trabalhando dos outros jeitos, entende?
Então essa crítica a gente precisa
superar porque porque é um jeito, se a
pessoa quiser fazer daquele jeito, tá
bem. Se não pode fazer de outro jeito,
não tem nenhum problema.
Então vocês vão ver os os ensinamentos,
eles não vão ficar iguais, os diferentes
mestres vão dar diferentes instruções. É
isso. Mas se a gente resolver começar a
comparar e e olhar isso, nós estamos
perdendo nosso tempo, porque o que nós
precisamos fazer é desenvolver essa
familiaridade.
Então, por exemplo, esse exercício, um
exercício do Dr. aqui a visualizar a cor
vermelha no chakra básico, como se fosse
uma esfera, uma almofada sobre a qual
nós estamos apoiando o perínio, uma cor
branca no topo da cabeça, uma cor azul
no coração.
É assim, a gente faz assim, pá, pronto,
agora eu vou entrar nesse campo maluco,
né?
Era assim.
Nós vamos entrar então nesse campo
maluco,
>> com certeza. Uhum.
Mas nada disso tem a ver com chás,
mas eu vou tomar uma um aqui para mim
inspirar um pouco.
E aí? Aí nós inspiramos,
enchemos bem o pulmão.
Enquanto isso, nós visualizamos a cor
vermelha como se fosse uma pequena
almofada abaixo do perínio.
vocês já e aí a gente contém a
respiração. Se vocês estão conseguindo
fazer isso,
vocês vão perceber que ninguém se sente
engasgado, sufocado por não respirar.
Seja a primeira coisa.
Então vocês,
se vocês não estão conseguindo ver a cor
vermelha, vocês, ali tem uma camisa
vermelha, vocês podem olhar ali, aqui
tem outra camisa vermelha. Vocês podem
olhar assim. Ah, tá. Aí vocês capturam
na mente
o que a gente diria casina da cor
vermelha, porque ninguém vê uma cor sem
ter casina correspondente.
Então a gente vê, a gente captura aquele
casino que é uma experiência interna. A
gente pensa a cor é externa, não é? A
cor é interna. Aí eu vejo aquela cor. Aí
nós podemos ver a cor e localizar a cor
nessa região. Aí nós inspiramos
reforçando essa cor.
Vocês podem fazer assim, vocês inspiram.
Depois de inspirar,
aí vocês inspiram mais um pouco. Vocês
vão ver que dá para inspirar mais um
pouco. Depois de inspirar mais um pouco,
vocês inspiram mais um pouco, porque dá
para inspirar mais um pouco.
Agora vocês olham a cor branca.
acima da cabeça.
Agora vocês olham a cor azul
transparente
na altura do coração e vocês expiram
junto com compaixão por todos os seres.
Se vocês fizerem uma vez, os canais já
se arrumam todinho. Só uma vez.
Se vocês estão com o nariz entupido,
dizem top.
Você não pode ficar mais do que meia
hora retendo a respiração.
Não, assim, não, não deixe nenhum
desconforto, não forcem nada.
Suspenda a respiração, passe paraa luz
branca. Espere um pouco aí, luz azul. Aí
vocês expiram tudo devagar. A inspiração
é lenta,
a visualização é o foco
e a expiração é lenta
e a visualização do benefício pros seres
é direta.
É o foco da nossa mente. Что?
Uma
variante pode ser assim.
Vocês se inspiram com cor vermelha.
E aí vocês passam por cada parte do
corpo
enquanto vocês estão subindo em direção
à cor branca.
E aí depois de novo passo paraa cor azul
e radinho para benefício de todos os
seres.
Quando nós estamos com energia
concentrada desse modo, simplesmente nós
passarmos com atenção sobre cada ponto
do corpo. É como se a energia surgisse
em cada ponto do corpo.
Então aqui eh eu não vou explicar muito
porque o ponto é nós fazermos isso, né?
Mas como eu sou um falador, eu não
consigo deixar de explicar um pouco.
Talvez assim, na verdade, na verdade,
pessoal, vocês vão perceber que nós
estamos fazendo essa transmutação,
porque a energia
da cor vermelha de baixo é a
energia associada ao nosso movimento
cármico pessoal.
A energia
associada à cor branca no topo da cabeça
é a energia associada à visão ampla.
Então nós unimos isso e manifestamos na
forma de compaixão. Então esse é o como
se houvesse um caminho inteiro
espiritual nisso. E nós saímos de um
ponto autocentrado, partimos paraa visão
e manifestamos compaixão pelos seres.
Na medida em que nós vamos desenvolvendo
a sensibilidade paraa energia, vocês vão
perceber em diferentes momentos que
vocês estão em algum lugar como que as
energias estão. Como é que vocês vão
perceber? Porque quando surgirem
exigências problemas dificuldades
aqui, ali, vocês de novo fazem assim,
onde tiverem.
Aí vocês vem que a energia tinha se
desorganizado total.
e a energia retorna.
Eu acho que isso interrompe depressão,
pelo menos momentaneamente.
Eh ela
resolve crises as mais variadas, porque
todos esses problemas eles vão surgir eh
manifestando
junto com os pensamentos da sexta
consciência tem as desorganizações de
energia.
E quando a energia se alinha,
a gente tem a sensação que as
dificuldades passaram,
porque a sensação que nós estamos em
perigo, em dificuldade, ela vem por
configurações de energia que a gente vê,
mas a gente não localiza.
Também vocês vão perceber assim, coisas
muito atraentes. Quando vocês
encontrarem coisas muito atraentes,
vocês respirem uma vez já.
Dá uma arrumada assim direto.
Aí quando a energia se alinha e a
compaixão brota,
esse referencial sutil que tá fora da
sexta consciência, ele surge com a
manifestação da sétima consciência como
a nossa identidade dentro de uma
região
mais livre e ela vai influenciar a nossa
ação dentro do do da bolha a partir da
sexta consciência. olhos, ouvidos, na
vez muda tudo.
Então isso é uma ação que se dá antes da
sexta consciência. Nós temos
referenciais de energia que a gente não
vê. Por exemplo, se vocês chegarem num
bifet, não, não é o aspecto cognitivo
que vai decidir como é que vocês vão
botar as coisas no prato, é a energia.
Aí vocês vão olhando brócolis,
vai ter assim, churrasco não, não.
Pastel não, não, não, não, não, não,
não não.
Arroz integral, sim, mas não muito.
Salada, sim, sim, sim. Bolo,
>> bolo não, não, não.
A pessoa olha para aquilo, não brota
nenhuma energia, você entende aí,
branquinho, não, não, não. E
alimento processado.
E aí, como é? A gente é comandado pelo
quê? Pela razão ou pelo movimento da
energia?
Aí antes do bif vocês
pode passar, pode passar.
Pá, estragou. Ia ter uma festa hoje.
Estragou tudo. Não, vamos deixar essa
parte. Agora eu me solto na natural
perfeição,
vamos em frente
assim. E a natural perfeição, o que é?
Qualquer coisa do Fendo, como é que é
isso?
Mas então nós estamos com esse ponto da
energia. A energia ela atua e nós não
estamos vendo, pessoal. Ela não é
lógica. Vocês dizem: "Não, brócolis,
brócolis brócolis brócolis brócolis
brócolis, brócolis. Pá, mas não adianta,
Lama. Eu acho que não adianta recitar o
mantra brócolis.
Não, não, não funciona.
Eu fico verde, mas não aquilo
é assim, não tem como.
por favor.
Eh, o senhor falou que energia no
momento em que a gente eh leva a
atenção, né, pro pro chakra eh raiz e aí
você visualiza, né, a cor eh vermelha,
enfim, todo o processo e mas que isso
não é cognitivo, né? Eh, porém em algum
nível eu não assim não consigo conceber
que eu consigo fazer esse movimento de
energia sem ter uma intenção,
sem ter um um algum tipo de, vamos dizer
assim, ação volitiva que vem por algum
tipo de afirmação.
Entende?
A a visualização ela não tem intenção. A
pessoa tá visualizando a cor vermelha,
ela tá só fazendo isso.
Não é assim, eu tô visualizando a cor
vermelha para não tô visualizando a cor
vermelha, pois eu visualizo a cor
branca. Nós estamos direcionando essa
essa natural ação, que é uma outra forma
de ação da mente.
Então, a gente tá se familiarizando com
outras formas de ação da mente, né?
Então isso é, eu vou deslizando para
dentro, eu vou ampliando, porque de modo
geral nós estamos operando com seis
consciências
que a gente vê aí a sétima, oitava elas
atuam, mas a gente não vê de modo geral,
mas a gente pode ver.
Então eu hoje vou, eu fiz essa
introdução assim, né, aspirando que a
gente progressivamente vai desenvolvendo
essa capacidade de olhar o aspecto de
energia. A gente não precisa
desenvolver
uma grande complicação. A gente precisa
um pouco só, porque o ponto central, nós
vamos fazer uma curva nessa prática,
porque senão essas coisas nós vamos
ficar presos por um longo tempo. Nós
vamos fazer uma curva disso. O processo
de baixo para cima, ele é um processo
muito extenso. Então eu posso, por
exemplo, começar a contemplar as
energias em cada uma das 108 posições,
108 asanas, aí usar diferentes formas de
respiração em cada asana. Aí eu posso
fazer as yogas de naropa. Aí eu tenho
não sei, uma vastidão de ensinamento.
Mas nós vamos fazer uma curva. Por quê?
que nós vamos passar um círculo em volta
disso tudo e vamos dizer luminosidade da
mente,
porque todas essas ações elas são pelo
aspecto de luminosidade da mente. Aí nós
voltamos pra luminosidade da mente, nós
vamos até oitava conscienso sem precisar
andar muito, mas nós precisamos andar
muito nesse âmbito da contemplação das
energias.
Então esse âmbito ele é necessário
porque ele é a linguagem do corpo e a
linguagem da energia. Ela não é a
linguagem cognitiva.
Por exemplo, se a gente vai levantar o
braço, a gente não diz braço, amigo meu
nós estamos assim muito tempo juntos,
casualmente desde o nascimento. Então
você levante, por favor, e o braço. Não
sei se eu quero. Você não se não tem
sido compassível comigo. Você só me dá
trabalho. Nunca diz obrigado. Digo não,
não. Nós temos uma boa relação. Levante
ele. Então tá. Aí ele levanta. Pois é,
pessoal, não é assim. A gente movimenta
a luminosidade da mente e a energia
surge nós botamos baixando.
Mas a gente também
a a minha mãe bane para ele, sua tia tá
indo embora. Nó tchau titi aí o braço
vai lá e abraço. Cognitivamente nós nós
relacionamos também,
mas na verdade aquilo tem uma bolha. e
tem uma construção e nós construímos
aquilo dentro de uma bolha
assim. Então o aspecto cognitivo ele
opera também, mas ele opera sempre do
mesmo jeito, através da luminosidade da
mente, do surgimento de uma identidade
que então faz alguma coisa.
E nós também operamos o nosso corpo a
partir das sensações internas do corpo,
que é uma outra coisa ainda, pessoal.
Assim.
Então, por exemplo, se vocês tiverem um
desconforto de corpo, a gente se move
pouco.
A gente se move porque tem uma sensação
de um inseto, tem uma sensação de uma
ardência numa parte do corpo. A gente
vai lá pr aquilo passa. Aí nós não vamos
fazer isso. Aí quando vocês tiverem
essas sensações,
aí vocês simplesmente inspiram,
visualiza a cor vermelha,
olha a cor branca,
olha a cor azul.
Ah, e vocês vão ver que, uau, aquele
processo cármico que tava ali, não é que
eu tenha dito desapareça pelo poder da
minha vontade, não. Mas é como eu foquei
a mente
na uma cor, na outra cor, na cor azul,
eu ocupei esse espaço. Então, eu não tô
olhando as sensações de de corpo e de
energia a partir dos aspectos cármicos
que vão brotando por dentro do corpo.
Então, eu vou me dar conta que existe
uma vastidão de aspectos cármicos
oscilando por dentro do corpo. Eu vou
olhando para eles como aquilo que vai
produzir então o impulso da energia de
um modo cármico.
Mesmo, por exemplo, se vocês estão
cansados,
se você simplesmente derem um uma um
único exercício desse, você enche bem o
pulmão.
O próprio carro não vai mais dizer para
vocês, tome um café e descanse um pouco.
Ele ele vai ver você.
assim. Então, esse é um é um aspecto
assim,
por favor,
delegação de Goiânia.
>> Bom dia, Lama.
>> Duas perguntas. Mas a primeira, a gente
segura o ar quando tá eh subindo e solta
eh quando tá no azul.
>> Primeira pergunta. A segunda é
>> tem variantes, né?
>> Aí vocês vão ver muitas variantes.
>> Eu já fiz esse exercício uma vez que o
senhor ensinou num
>> num retiro online e eu fiz no momento
que eu fiquei e com raiva de alguma
coisa, sei lá, ferida de ego, né?
>> Você ficou com raiva?
>> Fiquei. É, acredito. Fiquei lama.
Fiquei, reconheci e parei, falei, deixa
eu resolver isso aqui e super funcionou.
É, né? Que bom. E a segunda pergunta, o
senhor falou de vários momentos que a
gente pode fazer esse esse exercício e
eu queria saber se tem algum momento
onde a gente não deveria fazê-lo.
Eh, é porque eu fiz uma ligação meio
com, sei lá, com Daline, com a cor
vermelha, não sei se tem
contraindicação. Precaline.
Eu até evitei de fazer essa energia
subir pelo canal central. Não tá
subindo. Ela tá aqui. Daqui a pouco ela
tá aqui. Daqui a pouco ela tá aqui. Não
tá andando por lado nenhum.
Assim, nós vamos Isso é de baixo para
cima. Nós estamos fazendo tudo de cima
para baixo.
Então é assim, a energia tá aqui,
guarderia tá aqui. Eu não tô fazendo
aquilo magicamente subir, se acumular.
Então
que eu vou fazer a a energia e o karma.
da da do chakra básico se manifestar e
tão assumir. Não tô fazendo nada disso
porque isso ainda que seja uma das
práticas,
eu não vou considerar isso porque nós
vamos precisar pular por cima dessas
práticas. Então nós vamos direto para
luminosidade da mente, pessoal. Nós não
vamos fazer nada como se o corpo
realmente tivesse ali, como se os canais
tivessem ali, os chakras estivessem ali.
Nós vamos fazer nada disso. É tudo
vacuidade. Nós vamos pular lá pro final.
das práticas
aonde não não tem nada subindo, nada
descendo. O que tem é assim, se eu foco
a mente, aquilo tá ali. Então é muito
importante para nós entender. Se eu
focar a mente nessa cor vermelha, ela tá
ali. Se eu focar na cor branca, ela tá
ali. Se eu focar na cor azul, ela tá
ali. Por quê? Porque ela não precisa
transitar. Ela tá no espaço básico.
É assim.
E se vocês tiverem de noite, eh, por
exemplo, às vezes a gente, i, eu vou me
resfriar,
eu vou adoecer, ih, eu tô com dor aqui,
ali, isso aí, amanhã eu já sei, amanhã
eu vou est liquidado. Então, no meio da
noite vocês façam assim, vocês nem abram
o olho, vocês só façam isso, vocês vão
ver,
porque todas essas sensações, ela vê,
porque carmicamente os canais, os ventos
vão operando carmicamente
e de repente nós estamos numa
configuração de adoecimento,
aí vocês arrumam de novo
assim, as múltiplas doenças elas vão
surgir junto com diferentes
configurações. Aí vocês vão arrumando as
configurações, vocês localizaram
perturbação, vocês arrumam a
configuração qualquer momento das 24
horas do dia,
>> sem contraindicação.
>> Sem contraindicação,
não tem contraindicação, não vai
acontecer nada. Nós simplesmente estamos
pegando as energias
desorganizadas, organizando e
manifestando compaixão para todos os
seres. O aspecto cognitivo que vai
ocorrer é que a gente descobre: "Uau, eu
tava adoecendo e agora eu tô tomando
isso e surge como compaixão pelos seres
e os seres não vem isso." Então, nossa
compaixão, ela se amplia.
seria muito importante.
Os pensamentos são muito importantes,
os votos, banca,
a a cognição é muito importante, mas
vamos pensar, nós estamos operando
essencialmente, movimentando nossas
energias sem nem suspeitar. Onde é que
tá o inimigo?
O inimigo tá dentro.
Então vocês vão perceber, por exemplo,
todo mundo que faz prática, faz chamata,
faz qualquer prática de meditação. Se a
pessoa não arrumar energia junto,
ela não tá entendendo de onde tá
brotando as múltiplas perturbações.
Então, nós vamos ter a sensação de que a
gente disciplinou a mente, mas o o
demônio segue alimentando as coisas. Eu
não sei onde é que ele se esconde. Então
isso pode nos trazer uma uma sensação de
dúvida um certo momento. Eu não sei se
eu tô fazendo a prática que eu deveria
fazer, porque ainda que eu faça a
prática, os demônios seguem me
assediando.
Os demônios estão escondidos dentro do
corpo.
Por quê? Porque nós fazemos a nossa
prática e mantemos os demônios do corpo
calmos. Eles ficam lá, não, tudo bem. Eu
até faço chama até junto
depois. Tchau.
Isso aí não é problema nenhum.
Assim. Então nós temos um o os demônios
variados assim, associados a todas as
coisas. Estão todos eles lá calmos. Eles
aparecem aí pizza iood
e não sei quanta coisa mais aquilo. Tchã
tchã. E aí eles brilham dentro.
Então nós vamos precisar entender como é
que eles estão operando. Aí quando nós
vemos aquilo e a gente vai perceber,
pessoal, se a gente tiver padrões, olha
lá, aquilo aqui é prático.
Ele tava lá mostrando como é que pula,
como é que faz.
Aí se a gente não tiver essa
compreensão, existe uma operação super
importante da mente que a gente não tá
vendo e ela produz resultados.
Não.
Eh,
eh, não, mas eh essa prática também a
gente pode fazer nesses ambientes
tóxicos que a gente transita
>> com certeza
>> assim no especificamente eh, e às vezes
sinto em alguns momentos assim que toda
a minha energia foi sugada. Chego em
casa assim,
nãoé? Ah, e e como se proteger? Porque
semelhanamento e fogo, todos eles
desapareceram nesse nesse ambiente, né?
Não é assim, é que tu pensa que aquilo
desapareceu por causa do ambiente, mas
na verdade tem uma configuração de
energia que mudou, mas pelo poder da
natureza luminosa e da grande abertura,
tu faz a energia andar como tu quiser.
Então, tu te despede do aspecto
cognitivo e do ambiente e faz isso. Aí,
quando tu fizer isso, tu diz: "Uau,
eu não preciso ficar sobre o poder
disso". E eles precisam dessa compaixão
que eu tô manifestando. Aí fica todo
mundo teu aluno,
porque instantaneamente tu sente que tu
tem alguma coisa para oferecer para
eles.
Tem um ambiente tóxico, ele vira a terra
pura do Buda que vai nascer e vai, tendo
entendido aquilo, vai ajudar eles a a se
libertar.
Então, a energia ela tá, ela não é ainda
o aspecto
secreto, ela é ela não é a oitava
consciência, ela é a sétima consciência.
[Música]
Eh, dentro do CEB, da introdução à
meditação, a gente deveria propor essa
prática.
Essa é a primeira pergunta. A segunda,
se ela tem um nome assim que sintetize,
prática de energia. Você falou, Dr.
Nida talvez.
E ou se e se o cinco lunges ainda é
recomendável também a gente praticar na
introdução à meditação. É
>> assim, a gente pratica na introdução à
meditação, a gente pratica os cinco
lungas, porque já é isso.
E a gente deixa isso. Por quê? Porque se
a gente não tiver uma experiência
genuína nossa, a gente não tem como
transmitir, né? Assim.
Então, eu tô por enquanto, eu tô
convidando vocês para irem desenvolvendo
uma observação de um outro tipo de
operação da mente que existe. E aí eu
trouxe um roteiro para observação disso,
né?
Nós vamos seguindo assim de um modo.
Esse roteiro tem que ser muito muito
simples, porque senão começa a surgir
muitas questões e muitas. A gente
facilmente sai da prática e volta pra
sexta consciência, começa a olhar tudo
de modo causal, cognitivo, discursivo e
aí perde a prática de novo.
>> Teria um nome, Lama, um nome sintetiz
nome que dá
é desalonga, é a circulação de energia.
Alongue a energia, essa longue
circulação, consente da energia,
>> por favor.
>> Não, eu tava aqui meditando um pouco na
força da sanga, né?
>> Uhum. essa relação de refúgio na própria
sanga,
>> porque ao longo de práticas e tudo, eu
me dei conta que é muito útil sempre
sentar,
eh, fazer uma prática de cultura
pessoal, mas quando estamos em sanga,
eh, a força é bem diferenciada, porque
são várias individualidades
com o propósito comum e isso cria um
campo É,
>> eu me dei conta disso, não só meditando,
mas em coisas muito pontuais, até no
esporte.
>> Vai fazer uma coisa sozinho é uma coisa,
tem uma força,
>> vai fazer um pedal com
>> o mínimo a esposa, né? Não é o mínimo
>> isso.
>> Vai fazer um pedal com pessoas.
>> Espos.
>> Então eu me dei conta disso, de que até
existe isso na
na Agarta Sanga, né? conceito de agarra
>> é a soma de pequenas luzes
>> formam a luz do grande esplendor. E eu
me dei conta disso, que meditação
individual é bom,
>> mas quando estamos
>> em sang
>> Uhum,
>> eh esse poder se amplia não só de
entrega ao próprio caminho meditativo,
>> como na partilha com outros
>> irmãos da sanga, né? Esse esse conceito
de sangu achei interessante
>> com certeza
>> que é um refúgio. Realmente
>> é acho muito comovente a gente lembrar
que olha assim a gente nem entende como
que o Buda criou a sanga. O Buda foi,
mas a sanga segue até hoje e a gente tá
aqui e nós não sentimos sanga. Então
sanga é o próprio Buda. A gente pensa,
mas o que que movimenta? A gente volta
assim, o que que movimenta? é o aspecto
cognitivo. A gente vai dizer, não, não
é, é o aspecto de energia. É o aspecto
de energia junto com uma visão
do dharma, né? Então, se não tiver
aquilo,
né, a gente não tem a sang.
Se não tem energia, a gente não tá
unido. Mas tem um aspecto mágico. Por
que que eu vou chamar de mágico? Porque
o que não é mágico é racional, lógico,
discursivo, etc. Causal.
Quando eu não consigo entender, eu chamo
de mágico. Mas mágico é a manifestão de
são de energia. Então essa manifestação
de energia, ela vem do Buda, porque ela
vem da própria lucidez original do Buda.
Por isso que a sangue existe. Então a
sangue tá viva porque o Buda tá vivo.
Se vocês olharem, por exemplo, as sangas
que desaparecem,
elas eventualmente elas voltaram pro
aspecto cognitivo e elas abandonaram a
visão do Buda, elas estão no caminho e
elas sentem que o que elas precisam
fazer são
procedimentos
ou
talvez eventos para manter aquilo
grande. Mas aí é o caminho da do
desaparecimento,
porque nós vamos ser sustentados não
pelo processo causal, cognitivo, lógico,
discursivo,
mas nós somos sustentados pelo aspecto
luminoso da mente que tá fazendo prática
e tá vendo e tá conectada, que agora o
yoga
é assim, nós nos movemos magicamente,
nós não não nos movemos por causa de uma
explicação.
Vamos.
Você quer atravessar ela? A moça tá com
o microfone ali.
Os homens são assim, sabe? É isso,
>> Lama. Eu sinto que tenho dificuldade de
fazer visualização.
Eh, mesmo se falar assim: "Ah, imagina
uma maçã na sua frente, eu não consigo
muito bem imaginar assim". E aí você deu
essa dica de olhar pra cor antes, né? E
eu acho que isso ajuda, mas eu não
consigo sustentar isso. Ah,
>> não tem importância
isso aí. Tu faz esse recurso, olha para
uma camiseta vermelha, guarda vermelho,
aqui estão as lâmpadas também, ó.
Aí tu guarda isso aí, tu fecha o olho e
vê se tu vê o vermelho. Aí tu coloca o
vermelho ali. Então esse é um tipo de
ação luminosa.
Por exemplo, nós fazemos surgir a sílaba
T. De onde é que surge a sílaba T?
Do espaço à minha frente vai surgir a
sílaba T. O espaço básico da minha
mente, da liberdade natural da minha
mente surge plim.
Plim.
Tinha que fotografar o plim.
Aí surge aquilo. Mas de onde é que vem
aquilo? Aquilo não vem de lugar nenhum,
pessoal. E quando termina, para onde é
que vai? Vai para lugar nenhum.
É assim. Aí nós vamos lentamente vendo
essas configurações de energia também.
Elas vieram de onde? Elas vão para onde?
não vão para lugar nenhum. E nós, no dia
que a gente veio, a gente p essa parte
não quero nem pensar, né? Essa essa
brincadeira não quero fazer, né? Mas a
gente se dá conta, o nós de ontem já não
somos nós de hoje. O nós de 20 anos
atrás operava uma outra coisa, pessoal.
Nós tínhamos outras prioridades.
E para onde é que foi aquele ser cheio
de prioridades com energias de um tipo
ou de outro? Ele
assim
melhor entender isso. Mas quando a gente
entende isso, diz, mas e aí eu eu dou o
meu grito final. Ah, e sumo.
Mas o que que fica? O que fica é o que
sempre teve, que é a base livre de onde
nós podemos fazer surgir as energias, as
luminosidades, as luzes, as coisas
todas.
Aí a gente brinca no meio daquilo
assim, as nossas identidades é parecido
com aqueles brinquedos das crianças
também. Tu é isso, o outro é aquilo,
agora esse é assim e agora vamos jogar.
Assim, a gente joga, depois cessa.
Quando a gente cessa, para onde é que
foi aquele personagem? Foi para lugar
nenhum.
Porque Mas e aí? Eu desapareci. Não,
porque eu nunca fui aquilo. Eu sou essa
base de onde os personagens surgem.
Mas a gente, isso é cognitivo ainda, mas
agora a gente vai deslizando em direção
à energia. A gente vê que o personagem
surge com a energia, né? Assim, eu acho
que, por exemplo, os diretores de
teatro, os diretores de filme, eles têm
meios específicos, que eu já vi eles
criando situações aonde então a criança
chora mesmo, onde o adulto chora mesmo,
porque eles precisam filmar aquilo real.
Não é uma coisa fake assim,
não é?
[Risadas]
Aí você tem que quebrar isso, né,
Rafinha? Como é que faz para porque a
Rafinha é mestre de teatro?
Mais ou menos, né? Mas é isso aí. Ela
então esse é o ponto. Como fazer para
que a pessoa ela, vista o personagem,
ela tenha as emoções, aquilo de acordo,
né? Não é muito fácil.
Tudo bem? Então nós vamos adiante.
Deixa eu ver que oração aqui. 11.
>> Sim. Desculpa. Ah, tá. Pode falar o
microfone, por favor.
>> Eh, a gente pode considerar assim dentro
da visão dos cinco elementos
>> Uhum.
>> que a sang, a luminosidade da sang
princípio etérico o próprio Buda. O Buda
seria o princípio etérico
>> que gera a luminosidade da sanga. É.
É o segredo.
Pessoal, eu já vi centros budistas vir
exterior com apoio financeiro,
grandes faixas, prédios bonitos,
grandes, e não preser não não se
sustentarem. Eles vêm com bênçãos de
grandes mestres e não se sustentam.
Porque quando tu vai organizar isso, a
mente fica envenenada
pela causalidade.
E as tarefas que surgem são tarefas,
elas não são, não brotam do coração da
própria prática.
Então, a forma qual
os centros vão se sustentar e os grupos
vão sustentar sempre, sempre foi assim,
é o processo de que nós vamos nos
conectando com essa região. Aí surge a
sanga verdadeira. A sanga que não é
verdadeira, ela não é verdadeira porque
ela tá presa em compromissos da sexta
consciência para baixo. Ela tá presa em
tarefas.
seu ponto aí a energia vai baixando.
Então tem um processo de purificação da
sangra que eu acho maravilhoso,
porque quando a energia ela não tá sendo
sustentada, aquilo vai desaparecendo. Se
a gente sustentar a sanggou
total assim.
Por isso o Buda, a sustentação da sangre
foi doação.
Por quê? Porque as pessoas minimamente
elas olham e julgam se há uma sensação
de que tem mérito ou não
pela própria prática.
E então eu fico tranquilo porque a a
sangrado,
porque quando ela toma caminho errado, a
energia afunda.
Que não vai não vai para lugar nenhum.
Não é, por exemplo, o governo, né?
Se a gente toma decisões erradas, mas a
gente assume o poder, os impostos seguem
andando e tu pode fazer o que tu bem
achar em qualquer direção e aquilo ainda
mais tu consegue manipular a opinião
pública através de de vários processos,
né? Então tu domina uma máquina que tá
andando, mas a sanga não gera recursos.
Se faltar,
ela vive de doações. Se faltar o mérito,
as doações desaparece. A sanga
desaparece junto, porque as pessoas se
enganam por um tempo, mas depois não
mais.
É assim,
aí aquilo desaparece.
Isso sempre foi assim. Tá cheio de
exemplos desses da época do Buda, né?
Por exemplo, o Buda enfrentou alguns
problemas. Eu não vou contar as
histórias todas assim complexas, né? Mas
eu lembro que uma uma das histórias que
se conta é que o Muda dava ensinamento
de como eliminar as diferenças entre a
sangue, como que evitar os conflitos. E
teve um momento em que as pessoas
pediram para ele não falar mais, que
eles iam resolver o conflito na
discussão mesmo e pronto,
né? Aí o Buda se levantou e vazou.
Ninguém viu Buda. Foi. Aí ele foi para
outra cidade,
foi para outra para outra sanga. E
aquela sanga seguiu lá.
No dia seguinte eles foram mendigar na
cidade. As pessoas não deram comida.
Sim, porque as pessoas disseram o Buda
foi embora, a Sanga tem algum problema.
Então aí aquilo não sustenta. Aí o que
que aconteceu? a sanga, os monges, tudo
de cabeça raspada, tudo com monge com
roupa laranja, manto laranja,
andando de pé descalço, mas eles presos
por ela, por essa delusão. Aí eles
começaram a ir um por um aonde o Buda
tava. Aí a Sanga deu uma olhada assim e
perguntou para Buda: "Esse pessoal aí
que tá chegando, que que a gente faz?"
Aí eu mandaria assim, não, vocês
simplesmente acolhem eles. Aí eles
entraram e pronto, acabou, acabou o
problema.
Sim. Então, desde aquele tempo a sang.
Então, a pior coisa que pode acontecer
para nós é uma multinacional adotar a
sanga.
Mas se você souber de alguma, me fala.
Não, não. Isso é é mortal, porque aí
aquilo se mantém, não é? Aí o que que
vai acontecer? Imediatamente surgem
pessoas superáveis que não estão com os
votos completamente arrumados, mas se
colocam como os gestores daquilo. Daqui
a pouco aquilo virou uma empresa,
entende?
Assim, não é interessante, pessoal, não
é o ponto, né? Então o nosso caminho é
nós vamos simplificando nossas vidas,
nós vamos praticando, o nosso olho vai
brilhando, é por uma outra dimensão, por
uma outra direção. Se faltam recursos,
isso tá ligado à nossa prática. nós
melhoramos a prática e aquilo tudo vai
acontecer e nós vamos indo
contexto agora
eu vou debate com a prece
a prece de tem um atraso
a sangra ela conhecida
companheirismo
e os três treinamentos mais elevados
esses três treinamentos mais elevados
eles se baseiam Especificamente
em
>> isso é a prática de das deidades, a
prática da energia e a prática da
natural perfeição.
Nós estamos fazendo isso, você não se
preocupe que nós estamos os três
treinamentos mais elevados. A gente só
olha isso. Na verdade, nós estamos meio
que focando o treinamento mais elevado.
>> Ô, Lama,
eh, eu queria fazer uma pergunta que não
é para mim, então vou me esforçar aqui,
>> tá?
>> Eh, eh,
por exemplo, agora o Lama tava
apresentando assim, né? E essa eh que o
lama não vai apresentar a energia
caminhando e que, enfim, a gente foca a
luz vermelha, a luz vermelha aparece
nesse sentido, né?
>> Então tá. Então nesse contexto, eh,
quando Lama tá apresentando os
ensinamentos e dando os exemplos de
vacuade, luminosidade, muitas vezes traz
exemplos como do templo, do jogo de
xadrez, do jogo de futebol,
>> que são exemplos das coisas que a gente
tá mais acostumado a ver, né? É,
>> mas eh e as pessoas que têm uma
facilidade de ver coisas que tão que não
surgem para olhos, ouvidos, nariz línguo
e tato e que então as outras pessoas não
compartilham, né? Aqui o templo a gente
compartilha porque surge pros nossos
olhos, né? Mas daí as pessoas que vem
coisas que surgem na mente delas.
>> Por que que tá o som estranho?
>> Não sei. Não sei.
>> Assim é.
>> Tá.
Eh,
então como que o Lama apresentaria esses
mesmos ensinamentos? Mas usando exemplos
que serviss
coisas assim,
>> é imagens que surgem pra mente dela
apenas. E aí, como que Lama apresentaria
esses exemplos para ela entender o mesmo
ensinamento isso aqui nesse contexto? E
essa essa é a primeira parte. E aí a
segunda parte seria se a pessoa tem uma
sensação de que tá eh eh entrando no
barbo da morte, que vai renascer, que
conselho que o lama daria para que ela
fizesse essa passagem com lucidez. Então
tem esses dois lados assim, né?
Isso depende um pouco do quanto a pessoa
já desenvolveu de habilidade assim, de
reconhecer vacuidade, né?
Esse é o ponto, né? Porque às vezes, por
exemplo, a pessoa vê coisas dentro, né?
Ela dá um sentido muito denso por
aquilo, como se fossem seres realmente
que ela tá vendo de algum lugar e aquilo
aquilo pode ser um problema, né? E então
eu às vezes vejo, por exemplo, os
praticantes começam a desenvolver
a eles têm essas visões internas. Às
vezes essas visões são muito imprecisas,
elas são até aquilo não funciona.
Por quê? Porque elas começam a ver
coisas que não que não são realmente,
né? E e a gente pode reconhecer, mas a
pessoa ela não tá se dando bem conta
disso, né? Não é do tipo assim, a pessoa
vê aqui
o
Michael Jackson vai morrer.
Elson diz: "Olha, o Michael Jackson tem
que cuidar porque senão ele vai morrer.
Pisão, ele já morreu."
Então vem uma coisa assim que não é,
entende? Que não tem como ser, porque
afinal aquilo não tem como. Então nós
podemos nos enganar. Então, quando a
pessoa olha esses mundos internos, é bom
ela olhar isso com cuidado, sabe? Eu já
acompanhei pessoas assim próximas
vendo coisas desse tipo. Eu não queria
ficar sempre dizendo: "Ah, mas isso não
é assim, isso aí não vai dar. Olha isso
aqui, né?" Então, as pessoas vão
desenvolvendo vaidade também, sabe?
Porque elas vêm coisas, elas acham que
aquilo, aí os outros não vêm, a pessoa
diz: "Não, só eu vejo". Aí surge um
processo que às vezes é bem complicado,
né? E e esse processo ele por vezes, eu
uma vez eu acompanhei uma senhora por
muitos anos e ela desenvolveu um tipo de
vaidade desse tipo também, mas como a
gente tinha uma certa proximidade, eu de
vez em quando eu dava uma real assim,
tá? Porque as pessoas se deram uma real
muito seguido, a pessoa te isola,
né? Então eu mantinha aquilo certo nível
para não perder a ligação, né?
E ela tinha uma sensação de que ela via
tudo que aconteceu pros filhos e para
todo mundo e tudo. E aí teve um filho
que morreu, ela não ficou sabendo.
Aquilo foi muito aquilo foi um abalo
assim, né, para ela, né? Porque o filho
morreu num outro país, ela não adivinhou
nada, não viu nada, não recebeu nenhuma
transmissão e nem e ela tinha uma
conexão com esse filho, né? Então aquilo
abala um pouco as certezas que as
pessoas têm. Eu também vi assim, muitas
vezes a pessoa disse: "Vai acontecer tal
coisa, isso e aquilo não acontecia".
Então eu acho que a gente deve ter um um
cuidado se a pessoa tem uma conexão
espírita assim dos espíritos que
aparecem, que transmite falam e, né?
Então é melhor ler o livro do Allan
Kardec, livro dos espíritos do Allan
Kardec, que o Allan Kardec vai dizer:
"Olha, cuide, você primeiro desenvolva
uma relação de confiança com o
espírito." Esse dê uma testada nele,
porque esses essas manifestações elas
por vezes elas são delusivas e os seres
não têm intenções muito claras e eles na
visão budista é assim, esses seres
também estão no sansara.
O que dá para entender também pelo livro
dos espíritos, porque por vezes os
médiuns estão ajudando seres que estão
em outro plano e não o contrário, né?
Então não existe uma razão de eu
considerar que os seres que se
manifestam mediunicamente eles estão
certos.
Assim, além do mais, na visão budista,
eh tudo que é falado de modo causal,
discursivo, etc. tem um âmbito. Então
nós vamos perceber a maior parte dessas
manifestações, elas dizem respeito ao
próprio Sansara. As coisas que nos
preocupam no cotidiano, elas não são
manifestações que nos ajudam a
transcender a nossa vida limitada, mas
eles falam dentro da nossa bolha se nós
vamos ganhar ou não vamos ganhar alguma
coisa, se nós vamos ter prejuízos ou não
vamos ter prejuízo, se pessoas são
amigas ou inimigas, se nós vamos ser
traídos ou não, né? e eventualmente
alguns conselhos compassivos sobre como
que nós vamos lidar nas nossas vidas
delusivas. Então, na visão urdista, é
como se, na melhor das hipóteses, nós
estamos dentro do mundo dos seres
humanos, mundo condicionado, dentro do
reino humano, dentro do mundo do desejo.
E nós estamos recebendo um conselho de
um amigo sobre como que a gente deveria
andar melhor ou pior dentro do mundo do
desejo, mas não há propriamente uma uma
diferença que nos permita transcender
essas experiências, né?
Então, a gente precisa olhar com cuidado
isso para não reificar, não tornar isso
muito extraordinário, como se fosse
essencial, né? E
ah com respeito à segunda parte, né?
Ah, a pessoa sente que ela vai morrer,
então como fazer, né?
Ah,
esse ponto ele pode ser uma depressão,
ele pode ser uma perda de inserção no
mundo né?
Então, a pessoa pode estar vivendo uma
época em que a a sua própria identidade,
ela ela não tá encontrando um lugar para
andar direito. Então, por vezes, a gente
tem essa sensação de morte ou
eventualmente nós temos uma sensação que
a gente até deseja morte,
porque a gente também faz umas contas
assim: "Uau, eu para me reinserir
é muito trabalho e eu também não quero."
né? Então eu já vi assim de pessoas numa
certa idade, a pessoa diz: "Eu tô
vivendo sozinho,
né? Isso é muito triste. Eu não gosto de
viver sozinho, mas eu não tenho
paciência nenhuma para casar de novo,
por exemplo, começar tudo de novo,
contar tudo. Não, porque eu gosto disso,
eu gosto daquilo. E você já foi alto
para?" Não. Então vamos, né? Assim.
Você
conhece hotel tal não? Ah, aquilo é
muito lindo assim. E alto paraíso, tem
umas piscinas quentes lá em São Jorge.
Aquilo é muito bom. Você tem que ir lá.
Nós vamos juntos lá com certeza.
Aí, não, não, não, eu não quero mais.
Era assim
assim. Eu já tô um pouco cansado para
isso, mas por outro lado eu não quero
ficar sozinho.
É muito triste, muito ruim. Então já vi
isso, né? A pessoa não pá,
eu acho que deu essa vida deu.
Então pode ser que a pessoa tenha essa
sensação, né? E também minha
aposentadoria tá muito ruim, vou ter que
trabalhar mais. Eu acho que eu não
quero, né? Eu já tive uns desesperos
desse tipo assim. dizer não, não quero
aprender lidar com computador, não
quero.
Não quero trabalhar com outros
softwares, não quero não. Agora eu tô
assim, tô numa crise, não, não quero
trabalhar com inteligência artificial,
não não não.
Então tô invicto fiz uma consulta paraa
inteligência artificial
assim por enquanto, só pro Buda.
Desculpa,
>> ontem eu eu só ameacei, só brinquei
assim.
Aí, então esse é o ponto. Às vezes a
gente tá num nums portais assim, né? Às
vezes eu penso, esse mundo ele tá muito
assim, quando eu vejo certas ascensões
políticas assim, digo: "Pá, não, isso
vai demorar um tempo para passar isso,
eu vou ter que viver no meio disso."
Uau! Eu não mereço isso. Eu rezei tanto,
eu queria um mundo de amor. Me
enganaram, disseram que ia ter. Eu vim
para cá porque falaram de do da idade de
Aquários assim
né? Paz e amor e banho de cachoeira,
todo mundo feliz em roda. E agora deu
nisso, pessoal. O que que é isso?
Assim, eu ainda acredito. Paz e amor.
Banho de cachoeira. Assim, eu tô nesse
padrão. Mas fazer o que? O tempo tá
passando né?
É assim.
Então, às vezes a gente sente que tá
morrendo desse modo, né? Mas pode ser
que a pessoa esteja olhando paraa sua
própria energia e vendo aquilo meio
afundar. Mas a energia ela tá ligada ao
aspecto luminoso da mente.
Eu não queria assim decepcionar a
pessoa, mas a pessoa, na verdade, ela
não morre mesmo assim, porque essa
ainda que a onda bata contra a praia, a
natureza
última, a fonte da energia, fonte da
luminosidade que cria os mundos e e faz
tudo andar, ela segue, né? Aí termina a
pessoa achando interessante operar de
novo com olhos, ouvidos, nariz, língua,
tato e e mente. Senão também banho de
cachoeira não não funciona, né? Então a
pessoa ela começa, ela quer expandir
então aquelas direções e ela amplia a
direção de um corpo,
mas pode ser que a pessoa possa renascer
nesse mesmo corpo, nessa mesma vida. A
minha sugestão é essa, se a pessoa tem
energia no momento que ela tiver, a
melhor forma quando a gente se sente que
tá se aproximando da morte é é tentar
renascer nessa vida com esse mesmo
corpo, aproveitar um pouco mais, né?
Fazer uma
uma mudança de algum nível. Aí a energia
muda, tudo muda, a pessoa se sente
novinho de novo assim, né? Não importa o
que os outros digam, não importa o que
as fotos falem. Pessoa não, eu tô bem
assim agora, tô fazendo isso, fazendo
aquilo. Pessoa nasce a energia flui.
Então a gente vê pessoas que tão com
essa sensação de morte com pouca idade e
a gente vê pessoas que tão novinhas com
mais idade, porque isso é um processo de
como que a energia circula.
Então essa é a minha sugestão.
Eu acho que não é para você, mas tudo
bem.
>> Por favor.
>> Bom dia. Eh, tem duas perguntas, duas
questões que não ficam claras.
>> Eu posso fazer uma pergunta prévia? Você
tá vindo da onde?
>> Hã?
>> Tu tá vindo da onde?
>> Eu moro aqui em
>> Ah, tu mora aqui na aldeia 2 km.
>> Aham. Ah, tá. Então aqui em Alto
Paraíso.
>> É, é.
>> Tá
>> 1 km 12.
>> Eh, uma é sobre o tempo, né? Porque você
falou dos dos cinco elementos, o espaço,
>> aí teve na sexta-feira à noite você
falou algo que ah, se tiver não sei qual
apego ainda reencarna sete vezes. Se não
reencarna. Aí eu pensei, mas sete vezes
em qual linha do tempo, né? Onde é
simultâneo? Não é o tempo tá dentro da
bolha também, né? O tempo
>> é, o tempo tá dando bolha,
>> mas mesmo se a gente se renasce sete
vezes, isso não quer dizer tempo, por
incrível que pareça, porque é assim, é
um episódio, um episódio, um episódio,
um episódio. É como se houvesse uma
configuração da mente que eh induz, que
atrai novamente para que aquilo
aconteça, né? assim, mas os episódios de
nascimento eles são sempre atemporais. O
tempo começa a acontecer depois.
Eu acho que mesmo as crianças também
elas não tenham um sentido muito de
tempo. Eu eu até arriscaria que os
adolescentes também não têm. Os pais é
que ficam dizendo: "Tempo tá passando,
agora você isso. Cuidado que se você não
fizer isso agora, depois vai ser muito
mais difícil". Então seja um bom ser do
sansara, entende? né? Aprenda a fazer
isso, porque depois aí vem assim, eles
eles têm uma confiança,
eles têm uma confiança na eles vão
olhando assim e vão vivendo as coisas. É
como se eles tivessem durante um longo
tempo, a gente não tem uma consciência
de tempo.
Aí de repente aquilo surge, né?
E outra pergunta é sobre porque eu não
sei se tô compreendendo errado, mas é
necessário a intervenção de alguma
consciência fora da bolha, né, de um ser
iluminado para transmitir um ensinamento
para que os que recebem esse ensinamento
também possam se libertar da bolha. Mas
também é possível que a a própria bolha
ser uma espécie de a própria existência,
a própria terra ser uma espécie de de
trampolim, as experiências da vida, né?
O o ser iluminado também está na na
própria terra. Uhum.
>> Esse é o ensinamento Buddha, como que a
aparência delusiva é um caminho para nós
reconhecermos, porque aparência delusiva
das coisas que, enfim, a gente vai
chamar de bolha, ela ela surge cessa.
Então, ela surge luminosamente. Nós
vamos dizer, vamos chamar isso de uma um
surgimento luminoso, que é, por exemplo,
quando, de novo um jogo de tabuleiro,
que eu também não vou nomear, a gente
tem o jogo de tabuleiro,
eu vejo aquelas aqueles objetos ali, mas
aquilo não é o jogo ainda. O jogo
acontece quando a minha mente se
posiciona.
Então eu vou chamar esse processo, esse
flash, onde a mente se posiciona, vou
chamar uma manifestação luminosa.
Essa manifestação luminosa, ela dá
sentido a todas as peças do tabuleiro e
dá um sentido a nós mesmos.
E aí nós estamos engajados naquele
processo. A bolha é isso.
Aí quando eu começo a olhar como é que
aquela peça é vista daquele modo, eu
vejo o aspecto luminoso se manifestando.
Aí eu descubro, uau, é tudo mágico? Aí
eu começo a olhar aqui, por exemplo, eu
chamo isso de templo, mas isso também é
mágico, como uma peça de um jogo.
Aí nós olhamos a propriedade da área,
aquilo chega a dar um calafrio assim,
né? Porque a propriedade é uma coisa
muito esquisita,
é uma coisa delusiva, luminosa.
Aqui passaram muitos seres e continuam
passando seres e agora a gente tema que
nós somos os donos daqui.
E nós quem
tá certo que a sanga, a propriedade ser
da sang,
mas a sanga segue, como acontece desde a
época do Buda, né? Então eu acho isso
muito interessante, assim, a sanga
também ela tem um sentido compassivo e
expansivo, então ela sempre vai se
ampliando e nós individualmente
eh
os animais, as plantas dão uma olhada
para nós e diz: "Ih,
eu já vi muita gente aqui, muitos
documentos,
isso vai desaparecer,
mas os nossos documentos aqui, eu acho
que eles vão amarelar e vão
sigue no tempo assim, porque, enfim, a
sangas,
a nossa mente surge desse modo, tudo vai
circulando e vai andando
como Deus da época do Budas.
Então esse é o ponto. Quando nós olhamos
a natureza daquilo que a gente chama
realidade, a gente encontra as bolhas.
E quando nós encontramos as bolhas, nós
encontramos a mente luminosa que cria as
realidades né?
Então aqui é um pouco vergonhoso a gente
olhar e criar aqui a nós. É uma
construção luminosa da mente.
>> E então o o karma e você falou também na
sexta noite algo que ah, talvez ele tá
lá num paraíso e aí às vezes precisa,
né, de um karma para desper. você
comentou algo assim, desculpa, né, a
minha, eu não consigo colocar com as
mesmas palavras
>> e posso estar mal interpretando, mas o o
próprio Karma pode tá a serviço do
despertar de uma visão búsqua.
>> A gente tem o poder de fazer isso
acontecer,
porque o karma ele ele ajuda o
surgimento das bolhas de um certo
perfil e não de outros, né? Então o
karma que vai definir se a nossa
experiência de construção das realidades
é os infernos, por exemplo.
Ou por exemplo, a gente vê o jogo, vê as
pessoas jogando, a gente pode se engajar
no jogo, mas a gente pode, por exemplo,
preparar uma batida de banana, como as
mães fazem assim, com um pouquinho de
chocolate, levar para aqueles aqueles
jovens que estão ali vermelhos
e e a pessoa olha e ela vê aquilo de um
outro jeito, né?
Então, nós podemos olhar de muitos
modos, construir as realidades de muitos
modos. E essa, esse fato é um fato que
nos permite ver a natureza da realidade.
A natureza da realidade ela é
construída. Esse é o ponto.
Então, a gente pode aproveitar a
natureza delusiva, os karmas e todas as
manifestações, sem nenhuma exceção.
Todas as energias, todos os os mundos
dos infernos. A gente não precisa sair
dos infernos para para poder entender. A
gente pode entender pelos infernos
também. Por exemplo, se vocês tiverem
inimigos, não desperdíem
essa experiência. Vejam o aspecto
luminoso dos inimigos.
A gente não precisa primeiro se tornar
uma boa pessoa para depois ser lúcido. A
gente pode ser uma pessoa bem ruinzinha,
ficar lúcido, aí a gente abandona esse
aspecto delusivo da da nossa loucura,
né? Talvez seja mais fácil a gente
abandonar assim a loucura do que quando
nós somos pessoas muito boas, porque a
gente acha, não, agora eu sou uma pessoa
muito boa, né? Eu não quero ver o
aspecto delusivo disso, né?
Mas quando a gente tá uma pessoa bem
ruinzinha assim, a gente não se sente
bem.
Então a gente também quer se livrar
daquela sensação.
Mas a gente tem uma que fazer o caminho
verso. A gente tenta ficar todo mundo
bom que serve todo mundo de boa
intenção.
A gente cria sanga. Melhor não criar
nenhuma confusão. É assim.
>> Queria fazer uma pergunta.
por favor. Eu gosto disso. Esse
depoimento.
>> Acho que foi há uns 20 anos atrás
tava nesse lance, né? Nesse lance de
de depressão, acho que fazendo mal, mas
mais mal para mim mesmo. E
>> meio que no fundo do poço.
>> Mas o que que você fazia de mal? Vamos,
vamos botar
>> como como diz no
>> essa é a melhor parte. Como diz no, como
diz no Goiás, boca de siri. Boca de
>> Boca de Siri. Siri, podem, não pode
explorar tanto. Aí eu fui,
>> então a coisa era complicada, né?
>> Eu fui num centro espírita, né? Através
de um amigo, falou: "Não, vai lá tomar
um passe e tal".
>> E foi uma das primeiras vezes que eu
escutei algo, algo fora assim, né? Eu
tava com uma ex-namorada, eu lembro, e a
gente entrou numa salinha escura lá para
tomar o passe. Aí eu escutei nitidamente
assim no meu ouvido, né? Eu vou acabar
com a sua vida, maldito.
Aí eu falei: "Ô louco, né?" Tipo, olhei
para minha ex-namorada assim do lado,
né? Acho que é manipulação que tá
acontecendo aqui, né? Onde eu tô, né?
Tremendo um pouco. Acho que é o
microfone.
Aí
é, eu falei, aceita, né? Já, né? que que
será que você fez em outras vidas, né? E
eu ou tá pagando agora e por isso que
você tá no fundo do poço.
E
e aí eu fui procurar a ajuda do do
maestrão lá do centro, né? Falei: "Cara,
escutei isso, isso e isso, né, que eu
devo fazer, né?" Ele falou: "Não, a
gente vai orar aqui é mesa branca,
geralmente não tem espírito ruim, mas
alguma coisa acontecendo aí".
E minha ex-namorada, a partir daquele
dia, ela nunca mais quis voltar. Ficou
com medo, né? Ela ouviu também.
>> Ela não ouviu.
>> Foi ela que falou, talvez.
Não fo meio corr, né?
Ah, não foi, foi uma falha.
>> Eu acho que eu comecei a estudar o
budismo em 2012, um pouco mais assim,
que eu me envolvi com uns monges lá
perto onde eu morava lá. E aí veio esse
lance de ensinamentos de karma, né? Eu
falei: "Ah, acho que aquela fase eu
deveria ter passado por aquilo mesmo".
né? E
>> mas como é que tu sobreviveu?
>> Então, digamos que é um dia de cada vez,
né? Mas vamos indo
>> e e hoje eu entendo que eu tô numa fase
boa da vida, né? E que tudo aquilo
passou.
>> Uhum.
>> Né? Inclusive agradeço o momento agora
presente.
>> Uhum.
>> E mas só porque ela ela comentou do
centro espírita, tal, e eu lembrei
disso, né? Mas eu não eu não me assustei
muito não. Eu falei: "Ah, é isso mesmo,
né? Tô escutando e bola pra frente".
Mas eu fiquei intrigado porque que
aquele ser não apareceu mais.
Foi uma uma liberação.
Por favor,
tem uma mãozinha levantada lá atrás.
Olá,
bom dia.
Eh, algumas falas, né, sobre outras
religiões, outras crenças e ouvir
coisas, né? Queria entender qual que é a
sua visão em relação a isso, né? Eu sou
neta de mãe de santo, filha de pai de
santo, né? Já vi muitas coisas e já
andei em muitas religiões e não vejo com
um tom de piada ou desmerecimento, né,
nas coisas que podem ser vivenciadas,
ouvidas, vividas em outros ambientes,
né? Então, qual que é a visão do budismo
em relação a isso, né? A essa
mediunidade de ouvir, sentir, ver sobre
a própria vida, né? E sobre a vida de
outras pessoas, né, em muitos momentos
também.
É assim, quando
as diferentes tradições estão dentro
delas, né, elas são totalmente
coerentes. Então isso não tem nenhum
problema. Isso quando é visto desde a
perspectiva budista, ela vista da
perspectiva budista. É assim. Então,
inevitavelmente vai ter diferenças,
porque mesmo dentro das várias tradições
budistas, elas se criticam umas às
outras,
porque são são caminhos.
Eh, e na visão do grande caminho, todas
as tradições elas convergem pro mesmo
ponto. Então, tem um único ponto final,
então nós estamos indo naquela direção.
Agora,
as, por exemplo, a tradição espírita,
ela ela é crítica em relação a todas as
manifestações, né? Está dentro da
própria tradição. Por isso que eu digo,
olha, leio um livro do fundador, né?
Porque tá lá
o aspecto crítico em relação às várias
os vários surgimentos das várias coisas
dentro das das práticas espíritas mesmo,
né? Então, Allan Kardec
teve uma época que eu eu já era budista,
né? Mas eu tive uma hepatite e o meu
padrasto ela ele era muito espírita, a
minha mãe também era espírita. Aí ele
veio lá com uma pilha de livros, eu não
podia fugir, eu tava em quarentena.
Aí eu pensei, pá, vai ser agora. Aí eu
li tudo aquilo, fui lendo os
contemplando os textos e Allan Kardec
também, né? E o que me chamou muita
atenção isso, porque quando as pessoas
elas estão eh elas recebem comunicações,
frequentemente elas tomam aquilo como se
fosse absoluto,
né? Mas o próprio Allan Kardec, ele ele
chama atenção disso. E a visão budista
disso, né? Ela é assim: Ah, você observe
qual é o teor, aonde que se dá o
diálogo.
O diálogo se dá dentro de um mundo
sutil, que é igual ao nosso mundo aqui,
né? no sentido de que eu tenho eu tenho
orgulhos, invejas, desejos e apegos e
carências, raivas e aí nós estamos
lidando com isso. Então, na visão
budista, isso é um plano, um plano
sutil, específico, que nós vamos chamar
mundo do desejo. E a maior parte das
coisas ocorre ali. Então, é muito
difícil surgir alguma coisa
verdadeiramente transcendente. Que eu
até perguntaria o que que seria a essa
transcendência?
Porque nesse âmbito a transcendência é
nós abandonarmos emoções perturbadoras
de um tipo, manifestarmos compaixão e
amor.
Na visão budista, a compaixão e amor
causais dentro do mundo, elas não
liberam. Elas eventualmente podem até
produzir uma sensação de frustração,
porque a gente se move para ajudar os
seres e os seres fazem qualquer coisa.
Se, por exemplo, nós nos movermos para
beneficiar os seres e os seres depois
fazem coisas negativas, nós ficamos
muito frustrados e a gente eventualmente
nós podemos abandonar e passar e nos
tornarmos discrentes assim.
Isso é muito afletivo, né? Então vocês
se pensarem um pouco, vocês vão
encontrar várias pessoas que ajudaram
outras pessoas e foram traídos, foram
perturbados.
Desse modo vocês devem conhecer. Eu
agora tô acompanhando um caso super
triste também desse modo. Mas como a
pessoa tem uma visão elevada, ela não
afundou nos infernos e não tá acusando
ninguém, mas ela foi duramente atraçoada
para alguém que ela confiou totalmente
assim e a pessoa simplesmente criou
alguma coisa muito difícil de reverter.
Então aí aí fica assim, nós temos essa
armadilha, né? Por quê? Porque dentro do
mundo causal nós não temos uma
compreensão. Mas aqui nós estamos
olhando as oito consciências, nós
estamos olhando essas regiões que a
gente não vê, né? que aqui nós estamos
olhando o que que a gente visualiza,
estamos olhando as cores, as energias e
a oitava consciência que corresponde
o aspecto da grande abertura onde todos
esses mundos surgem, né?
E assim a gente ultrapassa essa esse
âmbito de manifestação.
Então eu somaria ao que Allan Kardec
falou essa noção. Veja que mundo você tá
olhando, porque pode ser que a pessoa
dentro dessa conexão, a pessoa apenas
veja esse mundo, ela não veja mais nada.
Ela pense que aqui é é tudo, né? Então,
esse é o ponto. Então, eu acho que, por
exemplo ah
quando os diálogos entre as tradições se
dão, o primeiro ponto é o respeito, que
cada tradição ela produz o seu resultado
dentro do seu contexto e aquilo tá bem,
né?
Por outro lado, ah, a gente também pode
trocar uns com os outros e ver o que que
uns estão vendo, o que que os outros
estão vendo, porque nós somos os mesmos
seres humanos, né? Assim. Então eu acho
que quando a gente se aproxima de outra
tradição, é preferível que a gente
coloque o nosso vaso abaixo do outro,
porque senão o outro não consegue
colocar nada dentro do nosso vaso. Então
a gente tá ali para ouvir,
quando a gente entra num outro centro, a
gente faz prostrações pros mestres do
outro centro, senão a gente não vai
aprender nada também.
Esse é o ponto, né?
por favor.
>> Bom dia, Lama.
>> Bom dia.
>> Eh, em relação às bolhas,
>> Uhum.
>> Eh, por que eu
eu vejo, eh, todos nós aqui temos uma
vida de nascimento, crescimento, estamos
aqui, né? Tá?
>> Eh,
tem, nós criamos várias bolhas nesse
percurso, porém elas estão todas
interligadas à nossa existência.
>> Uhum.
>> Eh, porém tem algumas bolhas, eh, vamos
dizer, dos infernos.
>> Uhum. seria uma culpa e que nos eh
prendem e nos atraem a a ficar voltando.
Eh,
>> teria alguma alguma indicação de
possibilidade de dissolução desse tipo
de bolha,
eh, que seria
conveniente para que a gente pudesse se
libertar definitivamente?
O, eh, existe isso, esse esse processo
ele é interessante de observar assim,
porque, por exemplo, as bolhas elas a
gente pode observar como um processo que
me aprisiona, mas por outro lado, quando
eu entendo o funcionamento dela, delas,
elas são um exemplo acabado da natureza
livre da mente que cria realidades.
Então, a bolha mesmo que nos prende,
ela é o remédio que eu posso, eu, eu
tiro o remédio dela mesmo. É como se ela
fosse o veneno que nos envenena, mas nós
olhamos para aquele veneno com um olho
lúcido, ele vira o remédio que nos cura
daquilo e nos cura das outras coisas
todas também.
Então, o caminho do Buda, ele vem nessa
direção de eu aproveitar as aparências
como elas estão.
Naturalmente, por exemplo, se a pessoa
não consegue fazer isso, aí tem os
instamentos anteriores,
né? Por exemplo, no início, se a pessoa
não tiver essa capacidade de operar
desse modo, o Buda vai dizer: "Não faça
isso, não faça aquilo", etc. Levite,
porque se você fizer isso, você vai
ficar cada vez mais preso e mais aflito.
Mas se você tiver lucidez, aí vocês têm
coragem. Então o tantrayana, que aqui
foi mencionado, né, surgiu essa palavra
tantraana. Tô trainando o caminho onde
você tem coragem, mas tem habilidade
também, ou seja, não mexe em nada, só
olha com olho, um olho reto ali. Aí tu
vê e dali mesmo brota o ensinamento, que
é o que nós estamos fazendo o tempo
todo. Nós estamos tentando olhar aquilo
como se apresenta.
Por exemplo, surge a raiva e o desejo de
matar dos infernos. a gente olha de novo
e vê que aquilo é uma manifestação
vazia, luminosa. Não preciso fazer
aquilo,
mesmo que surja uma, como é que eu vou
dizer? Uma
aparente causalidade, né? Por exemplo,
nós estamos olhando agora a situação em
Gasa, né? Que é uma das situações piores
que eu já pude imaginar, porque ela é
muito prolongada e muito cruel, tá? A
gente pode dizer: "Bom, então tem seres
lá horríveis mesmo. É só matando, só
matando eles,
né? Agora, se a gente pensar isso, nós
estamos presos dentro da bulha. Então, a
primeira coisa que a gente tem que
evitar é isso, né? Isso é ação de poder.
Aí nós precisamos visualizar eles
livres de dessa febre da loucura.
E aí a gente vai ver, não, claro, essa
febre da loucura vai terminar. Não sei
quando, mas termina.
Aí de repente eles estão em roda, né?
Como eu vi também quando, por exemplo,
os Rutes e os como é que era o nome do
outro povo?
na África. Tutes, tutsos, rutes. Eles,
aquilo foi horrível, pessoal. Foi assim
pavoroso, porque eles se matavam com
facão,
eles se mutilavam.
Por exemplo, tu descobre que é melhor do
que matar é mutilar o adversário, porque
se tu corta um pé dele, um braço, ele
vira um peso pro grupo,
mais do que um morto, porque o morto
enterra e segue a vida.
Mas se tu mutila e e e e e incapacita,
precisa uns três para cuidar dele. Vocês
entendem? Então eles usavam o facão para
isso. Aí tem os diálogos assim, o
professor aí ele foi cercado, ele
disseram: "Qual é o braço que tu quer
que eu que eu corte?" Vou cortar um
braço. Disse: "Mas sou professor, eu
preciso disso para dar aula". Tá. Então
vou cortar o braço esquerdo.
É assim, pessoal. Mas teve o dia que
terminou isso. Aí quando termina, o que
que acontece? Vai ser todo mundo
julgado?
Não, tem um ressete, né? Que é uma
palavra que hoje me arrepia um pouco.
Aí tem um reset. Vamos, vamos melhorar
essa palavra.
Aí as pessoas sentam em roda. Aí tem os
diálogos de os diálogos de pacificação e
cura.
Aí tem um diálogo que me chamou atenção
assim. Por quê? Porque eles viviam
juntos,
mas as potências europeias elas
estimularam o antagonismo.
Então as pessoas se tornaram inimigas
porque veio um tipo de ideologia que
cultivou a inimizade, eles começaram a
se matar. Então, se tu quiser dominar as
pessoas, tu faz os russos e os
ucranianos se matarem, entende? É assim.
Por quê? Porque aí tu chega naquela
região, tá todo mundo enfraquecido
e aí tu não gasta os teus soldados.
Assim, as potências europeias não têm
poder para entrar na África. Então elas
vão vão produzindo essas essas brigas.
Eles primeiro criam os países
artificiais, botam povos que não viviam
juntos juntos. E aí depois eles vão
estimulando esse tipo de coisa, né?
Mas aí tem esse, então eles viviam
juntos, as pessoas que se matavam, elas
estavam próximas, elas eram vizinhos, se
conheciam.
Então eu tenho o diálogo de uma de uma
senhora, ela dizendo,
ela dizendo: "Meus filhos foram mortos
e tu fosse a pessoa que matou eles,
apontando pro outro que tava ali, que
era um jovem. Ela disse: "Agora tu é o
meu filho.
Agora tu vai me cuidar e eu vou te
cuidar."
Então aí
assim, então vai ter esse momento que os
os palestinos e os judeus vão sentar em
roda, eles vão dizer isso uns pros
outros e os ucranianos e os russos
também.
Então tem um momento que aquilo, aquela
febre, aquela doença termina. Se vocês
olharem a Europa, a Europa tá numa
configuração depois de não sei quantas
infinitas guerras.
Eles se mataram de todos os jeitos.
Todos eles se mataram o tempo todo lá. A
Finlândia
dominou partes da Rússia.
A Rússia antes de surgir era predada
pelos finlandeses, pelos polonêes. A
Rússia não tinha nome.
Ela era predada pelos, vamos chamar
assim, para piorar um pouco a coisa, era
predada pelos chineses, mas não eram
chineses, eram os mongóis,
mas eram os asiáticos,
né?
Então os mongóis que também invadiram a
China, a China também sofreu dentro dos
mongóis. foi foi muito ah predada e a
Índia também sofreu com os mongóis, né?
Os japoneses sofreram duas invasões
mongóias que milagrosamente, não sei se
vocês souberam, acompanharam isso quando
aconteceu, né? Eu tava lá.
[Risadas]
Aquilo foi muito bonito. Aquilo foi
muito bonito. Como que os japoneses
escaparam, né? Pá, foi incrível.
Mas aí os mongóis dominaram a a Rússia
por 600 anos. Então vocês vão ver os
rostos, eles têm um olho um pouquinho
mais fininho e a maçã de rosto um
pouquinho mais larga, porque assim, eles
se misturaram geneticamente lá
e eles, os russos, tiveram que enfrentar
o império otomano que foi até a Hungria.
O Império Otomano fez o cerco de Viana
duas vezes.
É assim.
Então, a Europa é isso. E cada vez que
as forças invasoras vão embora, elas
deixam um núcleo que vinha junto, que
ficam ficam populações por ali. Então, a
Europa ela tá, por exemplo, a Bóia,
todas as regiões elas estão cheias de
islâmicos e vários
assim, com a espada na mão, a Europa
segue assim. E as histórias da Europa,
por exemplo, teve um tempo que a Polônia
desapareceu
porque ela foi invadida por todo mundo,
não sobrou nem um pedacinho para chamar
de Polônia, depois ela foi
reconstituída, né? Então é histórias de
extermínio étnico, de limpeza étnica.
Os ucranianos, por exemplo, limpando
regiões da Polônia, tirando os
poloneses. Aí depois tem outras, outros
tempos os poloneses tirando os
ucranianos.
tirando é assim, matando todo mundo que
eles podiam ver.
Então, nós temos agora, por exemplo, uma
limpeza étnica em Gasa, né?
Chamar de limpeza é assim, é horrível,
né? Mas as pessoas vão chamando disso.
Então, nós nós temos um passado
horrível, mas as pessoas aquilo passa
mais ou menos, né?
Então tem o tempo em que a febre cessa,
aí as pessoas se juntam.
O que eu acho assim, ó, não vou longe
porque essas histórias elas são longas,
né? As invasões viking do da Europa, né?
A invasão viking, a França Paris
cercada né?
Aí o acordo dos vikings com o rei da
França. Aí ele cede a Normandia pros
vikings para protegerem de outros
vikings que possam invadir. Aí na
Normandia eles se expandem e se
expandem.
Aí eles invadem
a Inglaterra.
Aí eles fazem uma limpeza étnica dos
saxões
e a corte inglesa começa a falar francês
até hoje.
Os que hoje são a o o a nobreza da da
Inglaterra, ela surge dos franceses
e essa língua francesa vai se misturando
com o saxão e vai virando inglês.
Então, a invasão francesa da da
Inglaterra foi vitoriosa.
É muito comovente assim, porque até hoje
tem uma tensão entre a França e a
Inglaterra,
mas a França é um país viking.
Aí eles expandiram, dominaram o mundo
inteiro.
É assim.
E os reinos, os reinos godos e vizigodos
são bem parecidas. Eles provavelmente
também eram esses povos nórdicos. Bom,
eles eram os povos nórdicos que chegaram
no sul da Europa e invadiram e dividiram
o planeta entre Espanha e Portugal.
Então, nós estamos ainda nesse tempo,
pessoal.
Agora, depois de invadir tudo, nós
estamos invadindo as florestas, matando
os animais e o espírito de expansão ele
segue.
Assim, predaram a Ásia, mas agora a Ásia
se juntou, eles deram as mãos, eles
disseram: "Agora nós vamos manter uma
estabilidade, nós vamos fazer uma outra
coisa". E o espírito viking godo
vizigodo tá um pouco engasgado. Nós
estamos vivendo essa transição histórica
assim nesse tempo de agora.
E os asiáticos calmamente vão conter
isso.
Se vocês olharem,
o Japão ele tem uma base budista muito
grande. Coreia é uma base budista muito
grande. A Tailândia essencialmente
budista.
A a China é essencialmente budista. é o
maior país budista do mundo. Onde tem
mais budista é a China. A gente não ouve
isso, né? A gente pensa assim: "A China
matou todos os budistas que pôde,
mas é o maior país budista, porque nós
estamos a mídia ocidental, né? A gente
não vê as coisas acontecendo
assim. Vocês v agora o Xijiping teve em
Lasa.
A gente não entende que o Xiping ele foi
predado pela revolução cultural, ele a
família dele, do mesmo modo que os
tibetanos também foram.
Todas as culturas tradicionais da China
foram foram predadas pela mesma
revolução de 59, que foi uma revolução
dentro da revolução
que destruiu tudo.
O Xeping ele tá reconstruindo.
Então, eu vi agora a o Xiping na em Lasa
teatro ao ar livre, gigantesco, com
centenas de pessoas, com um cenário
super bonito, totalmente tibetano.
E eles eh e eles encenando a vida de
Gazar. Gazer é uma manifestação de Gru
Poch.
E lá ping lá assistindo aquilo. Ele tá
recuperando os templos todos apoiando
da
Lama. Não tava havendo um movimento da
China ah com um outro pan em lama para o
substituto do Dalai Lama. Ah. esse
movimento todo que a China vem fazendo
pra escolha, né, do próprio do sucessor
do Dalai Lama e que agora também foi um
movimento que Dalilama disse que vai, o
renascimento vai ser fora da China,
>> etc.
Eh, eu não sei, eu eu vendo um pouco
disso, me preocupa esse movimento dele
tá mostrando um lado talvez eh
compassível tibetano, sendo que a parte
política,
>> né, por trás, pelo menos as notícias,
elas apontam com esse olhar
>> de meio de destruição da linhagem.
>> Uhum.
>> Não sei se o pode falar um pouco sobre
isso.
>> Sim, vou falar. é que pros chineses o da
leilama é um caso particular. Por
exemplo, eu podia pensar, bom, existe o
budismo e todo o budismo é o da Lailama,
mas não é.
Então vocês olham, por exemplo, larangar
é um é um, eu acho que é o maior templo
budista do mundo, tá dentro da China,
é gigantesco. Se vocês olham, não sei
aqui, eu diria que
Mas vocês o botam larangar, as
fotografias são incríveis. muitos
grandes templos numa área coalhada de de
eh casas de praticantes assim, é gigante
aquilo. Os chineses contiveram a
expansão porque aquilo tem um risco de
incêndio assim, né? Porque é tudo junto
e tem uma questão de saúde pública ali.
Se tu não cuidar, as casas estão todas
empilhadas, né? Tu tem precisa de
eletidade, de água, etc. Eles foram
criando, não criaram como aqui o SEB,
né?
Tem uma áreazinha de 300 m ou de 500 m
que tem as mandalas, tem a circulação,
se for juntando tudo como se as casinhas
tivesse tudo aqui do lado,
uma grudada na outra assim, né? E então
é um templo muito grande. Nós recebemos
instruções desses mestres de lá, né?
Então aquilo nós temos uma conexão, C
tem uma conexão com eles. Essa conexão
curiosamente ela vem pelo Soldar
Guerrinho Pocher, que deu os
ensinamentos do Surangama,
né, que a gente assistiu e também ele
deu os os ensinamentos de Rzon, que a
gente ainda não estudou em grupo, que eu
espero mais adiante a gente ter essa
oportunidade, né? Mas eles estão vivos,
eles são a segunda geração de mestres
lá. Eles sobreviveram à revolução
cultural, se mantiveram vivos.
Agora nós vamos receber também o Andrem
Pochê. O Andrem Pochê é aluno de lá
também,
só que ele viaja de lá. Ele agora tava
lá na o Tibet, agora ele recebeu, ele
voltou paraos Estados Unidos e ontem
eles estavam em contato comigo, porque
nós temos que combinar o programa deles
aqui no Brasil, beleza? onde a gente
mais ou menos combinou que eles vêm
entre agosto e setembro.
Ele o Anan Tuboch
vai ser um grande evento assim, ele é um
grande lama. Ele é ele é uma ele é uma
sucessão direta de do John Limpa.
Ele é o neto dele,
>> bisneto do John Lima.
Então a gente sai estud estudando os
ensinamentos do John Limpa, vem o
bisneto dele aqui que representa
linhagem, né? Então é muito é muito
incrível. Mas onde é que essa linhagem
tá preservada desse modo? Lá dentro da
China.
Então para nós é como se o budismo
inteiro fosse o da leilama,
mas o budismo ele é muito mais amplo.
Então tem as contradições naturais. Os
chineses vão dizer: "Não, nós temos a
questão do Daailama e dos refugiados na
Índia.
Isso é uma questão que tá delimitada,
mas isso não é o processo todo. Então a
gente pode pensar, bom, o budismo
desapareceu dentro da China de
desapareceu dentro de Bet, mas não
desapareceu
mesmo em Lázo, vocês vão ver, não tá?
E do mesmo modo que houve um
renascimento,
um renascimento, do mesmo modo houve um
renascimento das outras tradições
budistas dentro da China também, as
tradições chinesas. É assim, o mundo ele
é assim. E o budismo ele passa pelas
várias coisas, mas sobrevive.
Isso.
>> Então nós temos essa conexão com sua
santidade da lei lama. a gente recita
longa vida dele o tempo todo. Recebemos
os lamas aqui que vieram que vieram da
Índia, né, que estão nos campos de
refugiado.
Mas eh existe essa coisa muito ampla,
né? Aqui no Brasil nós temos outro
mestre que vem de dentro da China, né,
que é que também nos visitou em Viamão,
teve lá conosco. Assim, eles têm suas
dificuldades,
né, porque todos os países têm suas
dificuldades né?
E se a gente pensar sobre isso assim,
né? Então eles têm um um sistema que as
pessoas vão ter que respeitar o mundo
político como ele foi estabelecido. Mas
isso não é uma coisa de agora. Quando o
Bodidarma entrou na China, o imperador
não entendeu ele. Ele também sentiu
reprimido. No tempo de Shanzan. Ele não
conseguia levar o Suranga para dentro da
China porque o imperador não permitia.
Ele levou dentro da pele,
que seria no braço aquilo
é assim, mas os imperadores passam e os
ensinamentos seguem. Então eu vejo
também
os centros de poder na China vão
surgindo e vão cessando, vão surgindo,
cessando e o dharma segue. Eu acho
maravilhoso que o dharma siga com todas
as contradições, né?
Mas
é assim, se a gente não reconhecer, não
vê, a gente se atrapalha,
porque é melhor ver as coisas como elas
estão né?
Sim.
Por exemplo, os tucos, eles estão sendo
apoiados, né? Os tucos nascem dentro da
China, eles ganham uma bolsa, vão sendo
apoiados financeiramente. Se vocês
olharem os templos estão todos
arrumados, tudo pintado, ajeitado,
arrumado.
Mas, por exemplo, se eles se juntarem
para fazer uma manifestação contra o
governo, aí aquilo vai dar problema,
entende assim?
Mas isso não é uma uma questão chinesa
apenas. Em qualquer lugar nós vamos ter
problema. Se vocês olharem hoje, os
Estados Unidos tá numa situação assim
impossível,
né? Porque a pessoa não pode nem dizer
qual é a estatística que a pessoa é
demitida.
Agora vocês imaginem se a gente dissesse
na China é assim, se a pessoa vem com
uma estatística que o governo não gosta,
ele demite a pessoa.
E a China é assim, quando ela não gosta
do Tribunal Penal Internacional, ela
bloqueia as contas financeiras, bloqueia
todos os bancos relacionados à pessoa,
pune, não deixa mais entrar nem viajar.
Que que vocês acham dos chineses? São
horríveis. Só que não, quem tá fazendo
isso são os Estados Unidos.
Aí a China resolveu punir o o Supremo
Tribunal Federal Brasileiro.
Foi o que ela fez.
Vocês olham a proporção. Nós estamos
tudo assim com uma cara normal assim,
né? Mas se fosse a China, nós queríamos
invadir a China, né? Aí assim, não sei
se vocês souberam que a China estacionou
um grande navio militar. na costa do rio
e pousou aviões não identificados em
Porto Alegre, em outros lugares que
desceram pessoas do serviço secreto.
Vocês imaginem como os chineses são
malignos?
Não sei como é que o Brasil permite essa
ingerência dos chineses.
Assim, eu também não sei como é que a
gente permite que outras nações façam
isso.
Eu vi as entrevistas do Porque as
pessoas foram entrevistadas. Quem é que
desceu dos aviões? Aí desceram seis
caras fortes assim
do sistema.
É, não é o corpo diplomático. Claro que
eles vão chegar, eles têm a diplomacia
já resolvida ali e agora o que que eles
vão fazer diplomaticamente, eu não tenho
muita clareza assim, mas tudo com aquela
cara chinesa, mongol, assim, eles
desceram ali.
Vocês entendem a desproporção que a
gente olha essas coisas.
Agora, se tivesse navios chineses,
militares, encostando a costa brasileira
para proteger o comércio com o Brasil,
que é muito maior do que o comércio com
os Estados Unidos, como é que a gente é
síntim?
Mas aí os chineses agora resolveram
invadir a Venezuela
e ganhar um lugar, porque ali é o maior
campo petrolífico do mundo e os chineses
querem esse petróleo. Então eles
revelaram a verdadeira face deles.
Agora vocês vejam, eles estão lá, os
americanos estão lá com os navios e nós
achamos tudo normal. A mídia acha tudo
normal assim. Então nós estamos nesse
passo entende?
É muito estranho.
Se os chineses disserem: "Olha, se a
Venezuela for invadida, nós vamos ajudar
a Venezuela. Os chineses são super
radicais,
eles são desproporcionalmente,
eles são desequilibrados
porque eles não têm nada que se meter
nisso.
Se vocês olharem a Venezuela, ela tá
bloqueada. né? A indústria deles
afundou. Por quê? Porque o Maduro é
horrível. Não, eles estão bloqueados
como a China, como Cuba tá bloqueada
como o Brasil.
Agora eles tentaram bloquear alguma
coisa, né? E a gente tá arriscado,
realmente,
porque, por exemplo, vocês olhem o
Xandão, vamos chamar assim, íntimo, né?
Ele ele não pode mais usar o Mastercard,
nem o Visa.
E que opções nós temos aqui?
Eu proponho o Banry Compras lá do Rio
Grande do Sul, pelo menos
assim Pix,
né? Mas, por exemplo, se eles bloqueiam
as contas dele, porque o banco que
permite que eles tenham conta eh tem
conexão com os bancos americanos.
Aí os bancos americanos, aliás, o
governo americano diz: "Se tiver
qualquer conta dele, nós vamos impedir
que esses bancos façam
transações com os americanos".
Assim, então nós estamos sobre um sobre
um cerco.
Quando ocorreu a guerra na Ucrânia, os
russos repentinamente, o país inteiro
repentinamente perdeu o Mastercard e o
Visa.
e perdeu o a o conserto e as peças de
reposição dos aviões.
Então, como é que tu vai manter aquela
frota de aviões? O país vai parar.
E aí, então nós estamos nesse nesse
âmbito assim, nós temos esse tipo de
dependência. Se isso fosse com chineses,
eu não sei o que que a gente ia dizer
assim né?
É o ponto. Porque eles são os monstros.
Essa é a imagem nossa, assim,
então eu vejo Gigipin calmamente
reconstruindo as coisas do jeito que é
possível.
Assim, com Dalilama, eles conversaram
muitas vezes, até agora nada foi
possível ainda, né?
Mas essa parte política eu evito olhar
assim.
Lelão, para mim, ele é um mestre dos
ensinamentos, né, das transmissões, uma
visão super ampla. Nós estamos vivendo
ainda um período que é o final da
Segunda Guerra Mundial, onde aquilo tudo
explodiu, né? As pessoas se dividiram ao
início da Guerra Fria. Então, Guerra
Fria ainda existe dentro dessa situação
com a santidade da Leila Mata ainda.
Isso tem uma hora que passa.
Não sei como é que nós estamos aqui de
senhor mais alguma pergunta.
Lama, eu me lembro uma vez uma mesa
redonda,
lá no fórum social mundial em Porto
Alegre, onde estava você e o Capra
e
e assim uma da das coisas, né, que ele
abriu assim, a mesa redonda falou:
"Olha, o Brasil é uma das maiores
potências do mundo, é a maior geradora
de biomassa, é é a que recebe maior
radiação fotovoltaica.
E se vocês fechassem as portas hoje pro
mundo, vocês já teriam um grande sucesso
por por ser. Então assim, a pergunta vai
no sentido de da situação cármica ou
dármica do território mesmo assim, né?
Porque nós estamos passando sim por um
momento que que pode a pode acontecer
algo muito muito forte em relação a
nível planetário e o o Brasil é uma um
possível refúgio, né, de sanga nessa
nessa linha mesmo de preservação da da
vida. E eu queria saber um pouco se
>> isso tá um pouco fora do nosso assunto
assim, né, aqui, mas tudo bem, nós
estamos no final do retiro também.
E na verdade, pessoal,
o que
eh o Brasil tá sendo hoje, nesse tempo
agora, ele tá sendo beneficiado
especialmente porque o Brasil não tem
inimigos.
E os brasileiros, eu eh outro dia eu
tava vendo uma entrevista de um alemão
que é brasileiro, ele tem dois
passaportes, né? Então ele disse, tem
certos lugares que não viajo com
passaporte alemão. Se eu tivesse um
passaporte americano, também não
mostraria.
Mas o passaporte brasileiro, quando eu
entro, as pessoas sorrem. Se eu digo que
eu sou brasileiro, todo mundo acha que
tá bem. Não tem nenhuma parte do mundo
que acha que os brasileiros, exceto
Argentina, claro que esse probleminha
assim,
não é nem Argentina. Argentinos são
nossos irmanos. amigos, muito amigos
assim,
mas então não tem lugares antagonizam
com os brasileiros, né? Nem Portugal
às vezes não assim, tem muito brasileiro
lá, o pessoal se sente um pouco, né? Mas
enfim. Ah,
eu acho que os portugueses sofrem um
pouco com o fato de que a língua
portuguesa brasileira tá ficando
popular.
né? As pessoas estão preferindo aprender
o português do Brasil do que o português
de Portugal. Eu não quero aqui me meter
nessa coisa, né?
Mas essencialmente o Brasil tem esse
perfil. Então agora eu vejo muitas
comunicações e comentários de que o
Brasil vai se tornar um país que vai
expandir muito. É a pátria do
capitalismo internacional. Eu fiquei
muito feliz.
Por quê? Porque vocês, olha, eh, eu vi
esse comentário bem claro nesse tempo de
agora, né? Por quê? Porque se tu vai
investir nos Estados Unidos, não sabe o
que que vai acontecer, porque a política
lá é flutuante.
Onde é que a política é mais estável?
Por incrível que pareça, pessoal,
é assim, aqui é mais estável. Por quê?
Porque pode surgir a loucura que for,
mas eles consegu eles seguem o o aspecto
comercial segue fluindo,
vocês entendem? Então eles estão achando
que aqui é mais vantajoso e isso vai
alterar a paridade de dólar com com
reais. Por quê? Porque começa a entrar
dólares e o real começa a subir. Então
isso é previsível assim, né? Se vocês
tiverem dólares,
comprem reais.
Comprei em ouros,
mas aí tem esse esse ponto, né, que é
esse papel. Então, tem muitas pessoas
que estão adivinhando isso. E eu acho
que, aliás, eu não tenho nenhuma dúvida,
porque do outro lado também da Ásia, o
Brasil é o é a ponte para essa região
que inclui México, Estados Unidos,
porque o Brasil tem essa fluidez, né,
incluindo os europeus, né? Então, se as
fábricas se localizam aqui, elas têm uma
possibilidade de de daqui
andar em várias direções, né? E os
chineses resolveram apostar no Brasil
como hub deles no exterior, né?
Isso tá definido. Então, eles estão, por
exemplo, estão fazendo investimentos.
Bom, eles já vinham fazendo há muito
tempo, né? Porque eles se deram conta
que não não dá para colocar as fábricas
aqui. Simplesmente
eles precisam ter energia paraas
fábricas. E não basta ter energia e as
fábricas eles precisam escoamento.
E não basta eles terem um escoamento
comum. Eles precisam escoar pro pro
Pacífico. Então eles estão criando essas
rotas. Agora nós estamos bem perto do
fim da primeira rota transoceânica. né,
que tu pode sair de de
os veículos de carga do do
Oceano
Atlântico em direção ao Pacífico e
despachar pro outro lado. Então, tudo
que é produzido no meio do continente,
em vez de seguir para o Atlântico e de
lá fazer uma grande volta pelo canal do
Panamá ou por baixo, né, até a Ásia,
eles pegam o mesmo trajeto e cruzam em
direção ao Chile ou ao Peru. E de lá
eles vão
direto pra Ásia, né?
algumas tradicionais
as florestas.
Isso é o desenvolvimento
capitalista,
isso é inevitável
assim. Mas aí a gente não tá num ponto
de conta e se desenvolvendo por
enquanto.
É assim.
Então isso é o aspecto geopolítico. Eu
não sei bem como é que isso vai
acontecer, essa parte de da das questões
ambientais, mas se vocês olharem as
questões ambientais hoje, elas estão em
terceira ou quarta prioridade, elas já
foram a primeira. Não porque os
problemas ambientais estejam se
reduzindo, não, eles estão se ampliando.
Mas nós introduzimos na agenda a guerra,
que é o primeiro ponto. Agora aí tem uma
guerra geopolítica, que é o segundo
ponto, que tá fundindo com o primeiro,
né? Essa guerra geopolítica, ela tem um
terceiro ponto que é uma guerra
econômica. Eu inclui um quarto ponto que
é autonomia dos Estados, porque os
estados estão agora ameaçados.
Se as pessoas podem se voltar pro pro
para Gurelândia, dizer: "Bom, isso aqui
agora vai ser meu". E pode se voltar ao
ao a Canadá e dizer: "Bom, agora isso
aqui é Estados Unidos, isso pode
qualquer coisa, pessoal".
né? Então, nós estamos num tempo
completamente
estranho. Então, essa essa noção ela não
é aleatória,
porque o capitalismo internacional
e os grandes grupos, eles preferem gerir
o planeta inteiro do que esperar que as
os países façam a sua gestão, né? Eles
acham que os países não estão fazendo
aquilo direito para o benefício das
próprias grandes organizações. Se vocês
olharem a organização do Elon Musk, por
exemplo, é maior do que muitos países.
É assim. Então eles têm um poder
econômico, só que eles são
transnacionais,
enquanto que os os países nacionais eles
são nacionais, então se eles vão
intervir num outro lugar aquilo funciona
muito bem. Mas então eles preferem
dividir o planeta dentro de uma visão de
liberalismo que nós precisamos maximizar
e melhorar os negócios. E aí nós vamos
ficar geridos simplesmente pelo grande
capitão,
que é algo que tá acontecendo, que eles
chamam de deep state, que eles não
aparecem, mas eles elegem os
republicanos, democratas, eles elegem
todo mundo em todo lugar para manter o
funcionamento,
né? Como eles têm muito poder, eles
decidem as coisas assim. Então eu vi uma
análise de como que o
essa visão ela surgiu, como que ela foi
alimentada, como que ela virou um
movimento popular, como que ela depôs a
Dilma e como que isso em vários países,
né, como que ela vai criando uma agenda
e vai se infiltrando de vários modos
assim nos lugares. Então, ela tá
associada à bancada evangélica, tá
associada a várias coisas aqui no Brasil
assim.
Então, nós estamos no meio, nós estamos
vivendo dias muito importantes pro
Brasil, assim, porque o Brasil vai ser
forçado a se alinhar.
Mas hoje não tem um alinhamento, tem uma
submissão. Vocês olham a Europa, a
Europa se submeteu. Agora, mesmo os
países que se submetem, como o Japão,
eles são penalizadas, eles se tornam
viáveis. Então nós estamos com um
momento bem delicado assim, se o Brasil
se submeter, não vai adiantar nada.
Então, hoje também é pouco comentado,
mas o Japão, a a Coreia e a China
fizeram uma
uma aliança de tarifa zero
entre eles. Então, esse equivale à
entrada do Japão nos bricks.
Vocês entendem? Porque ela porque a isso
é a entrada da Coreia. e do Japão nos
bricks, porque eles têm essa aliança de
livre comércio com a China. Então, a
China tá dentro dos brinques, eles estão
comercializando o livre. Ele, o Japão
também estabeleceu agora um uma relação
privilegiada com o Brasil.
Então, isso é alguma coisa relevante
assim. Mas isso tá E a agenda ambiental
onde é que tá?
Isso só vai aumentar o número de navios
andando de um lado pro outro. Mas vocês
entendam assim, do lado da Ásia, eles
estão operando com a visão de um futuro
sustentável que vai passar pela
transição de energia, pela pelo respeito
ao meio ambiente, pela o respeito à
população, etc. Eles estão com essa
agenda.
Então eu acho que tá muito estranho a
agenda, vamos dizer, ocidental dominada
por uma pessoa cujos próprios assessores
não conseguem entender.
Se vocês perguntarem paraa Iá que que o
Trump tá fazendo?
A Iá vai dizer: "Essa é uma pergunta
difícil
assim. Por quê? Porque vocês vão ver, os
próprios assessores não entendem bem e
os comentaristas inevitavelmente tão tão
comentando que ele tá destruindo os
Estados Unidos, tá destruindo a
respeitabilidade confiabilidade etc.
Então aquilo é muito perigoso para eles,
mas ao mesmo tempo ele pede a rendição
dos países. Então ele vai pedir a
rendição do Brasil, vai pedir a rendição
dos outros, assim pelo tamanho deles,
pelo tamanho deles. Ele chegam e diz:
"Bom, vai encarar?" Diz: "Não, não, não
vou encarar".
Então, nós estamos vivendo esses, eu eu
diria assim, é nesses dias, nessas
semanas, nesses meses, não sei quanto,
mas é agora. Eles estão pressionando o
STF, estão pressionando o governo
brasileiro, mandaram os navios ali. Por
que que vão mandar esses navios,
pessoal? Que que é isso? Entende? Então,
na primeira e segunda guerra aconteceu o
mesmo. O Brasil entrou depois de ser
pressionado.
Vocês estudarem aí como é que o Brasil
entrou na Segunda Guerra, vocês vão ver.
O Brasil foi pressionado.
Pressionado mesmo. Eles precisavam de
uma base. Então, surgiu a base, né, em
Fortaleza lá.
E os brasileiros foram treinados para
virar soldados e os brasileiros foram
muito importantes. Aquela batalha de
Monte Castelo, aquilo ele foi super
importante na Segunda Guerra Mundial,
porque a gente não se dá conta, a gente
não estuda isso, não sei por, mas não
estuda.
Houve o desembaque na Normandia, mas
houve um um desembarque no sul da
Itália.
Vocês entendem? Não foi só na Normandia.
E no sul da Itália estavam os
brasileiros.
Mas aí tinha uma cadeia de montanhas que
era onde havia essa fortaleza que era o
Monte Castelo, que os não conseguia
passar por pela cadeia de montanhas,
toda fortificada pelos alemães.
Ali nem era os italianos defendendo a
Itália, eram os alemães. E os
brasileiros subiram aquela montanha
levando o tiro e derrubaram aquilo e
conseguiram.
Os brasileiros foram bem importantes
nessa nesse aspecto estratégico.
Mas isso tudo é o sansara. Sansara é
assim. Se vocês voltarem 50 anos, 50
anos, 50 anos infinitamente, h.
Vocês só vão ver os grupos humanos, os
homens se matando assim.
É isso. Isso. Mas o que eu considero
positivo em tudo isso é que no meio de
tudo isso, o dharma ele flutua, pessoal.
Ele flutua. Ele não é dizimado no meio
disso.
E nós não somos dizimados por quê?
Porque a sangada.
Ela não é dizimada porque a sanga não
acredita nisso. A sanga cega com refúgio
no Budarm e sanga. É isso.
É assim. Eu acho que essa é a grande
notícia.
O o budismo praticamente desapareceu na
Índia num tempo. Agora o budismo tá de
volta na Índia.
E o budismo segue. Por quê? Porque ele
não é uma religião propriamente, é uma
lucidez diante das aparências. Essa é a
base do budismo. Refúgio no Buda, dar no
sangue é o refúgio na lucidez. Aí nós
vamos sobreviver a todas as fraturas.
Nós vamos, nós vamos sobreviver a tudo.
A gente não vai tomar lado em lugar
nenhum, mas nós vamos eh sempre manter
os mesmos valores. Esses valores são os
valores vitoriosos. Porque quando vem a
paz, o que que é? Nós precisamos nos
respeitar uns aos outros, considerar o
os diferentes e acolher, entender as
pessoas nos seus próprios mundos. Vamos
colaborar. Todos aspiram a felicidade,
aspiramos se livrar do sofrimento. A
gente se torna um colaborador de todo
mundo. Isso é o que nós fazemos.
Assim. Então, eu acho que quando a gente
contempla essas situações de Sansara,
talvez a maior lição seja entender como
que os ensinamentos e a sangrível
assim.
A gente também não ouve sobre isso
porque nós estamos num lugar que filtra
todas as as notícias, né? Mas, por
exemplo, a Rússia é o país europeu que
tem um um contato mais antigo com o
budismo.
E a Rússia é composta de várias regiões
autônomas ou semiautônomas. E tem pelo
menos uma região autônoma dentro da
Rússia da Rússia que chama Acácia, que é
um uma república budista
tibetana.
Então vocês botem aí, façam uma busca e
olhem, tá lá os templos tibetanos, eles
têm uma conexão com o budismo, o budismo
gelugam
da Lailana lá também
da Rússia. Tem mestres antigos que
traduziram textos importantes assim como
Sherbatsk. Tem vários lamas budistas, tu
olha para eles assim, aquele corpo
pesado com a roupa tibetana, aquele olho
de lince.
ele seguindo a tradição, mas é isso aqui
é o século retrasado, ele já tava com
isso.
Então nós temos várias contradições. Eu
acho interessante porque a gente se
considera dentro de um ambiente de livro
e informação, etc. Mas nós estamos com
as informações filtradas
assim. Então eu acho isso a gente tem
que anotar.
para lembrar isso, porque tem uma
sensação de que nós estamos num lugar
que a gente pode ver tudo, mas a gente
não vê tudo.
Eu acho assim comovente abrir os
jornais, tipo Folha de São Paulo, ah,
especialmente o estado de São Paulo, que
muito,
muito filtrado tudo.
microfone.
Só um minutinho aí Paulo. você vai
falar,
eh, primeiro agradecer aí o o
aula de relações internacionais.
Trabalho com isso todo dia e me e tava
lembrando de um retiro dessa área.
>> É, eu sou amigo do Léo, colega do Léo,
>> trabalho do PAR, né?
>> Ah, sim.
É o diplomata, né? Ele tá dentro disso.
>> Esse é o mundo de vocês, né? E para mim
o que foi mais interessante foi uma fala
de ontem que o senhor falou eh que vi a
situação atual com muito otimismo. Uhum.
>> Que é algo que eu não tenho ouvido
muito.
>> Eu continua vendo
>> porque eu tô vendo a Ásia pela Ásia,
entende? Era mais,
>> não é por aqui.
É que eu eu fico olhando como que a Ásia
tá andando. Então eles estão andando,
eles procuram não ter conflito.
>> Lama, quando ele falou isso, eu fiquei
nessa perspectiva também, né? Você falou
do otimismo ontem, hoje você falou muito
da guerra, né? Então me deu essa
impressão. Onde é que tá o otimismo aí
dentro?
>> É. É que eu vi eles fazendo isso, né?
Eles, por exemplo, uma fotografia assim,
um dos líderes da dos diferentes países
da Ásia, ele segura a mão do outro aqui,
segura a mão do outro aqui. Nós estamos
junto e nós não vamos abrir. Qual é o
nosso objetivo? É beneficiar as
populações, proteger o ambiente, ter um
sonho de futuro estável. Nós não
queremos guerra. Nós queremos facilitar
o comércio e facilitar as trocas. Nós
queremos um desenvolvimento real. Nós
queremos trocar a matriz energética. Nós
queremos redução do carbono, nós
queremos redução do impacto ambiental,
eh,
recuperação das áreas desérticas, evitar
a pobreza extrema, seguir as ODS da ONU.
É isso, pessoal.
Vocês olham a ODS, o que que eles têm o
objetivo da ODS. Agora quando começa os
painéis solares a chegarem em todo lugar
e os carros os carros elétricos chegarem
em todo lugar, tu diz eles são
invadindo, pessoal. Mas tem um plano que
é substituir o carro a combustão,
entendeu? Por quê? Por causa do carbono.
Aí o pessoal esqueceu totalmente isso.
Eles olham agora tudo como um jogo
geopolítico de dominação. Todo mundo
pode construir carro elétrico, pessoal.
Qual é o problema?
E tem um tem dois aspectos que estão
menos falados ainda,
mas eles vão se tornar muito relevantes,
né? Se vocês examinarem o aspecto,
eu acho assim muito difícil de reverter,
que é o fato de que, por exemplo, tu
pega um país como o Brasil, assim, aí tu
liga cada região que chega um trem
rápido ali, essa região se vincula
economicamente entende?
É simples.
Cada região que tu abre um túnel e cria
uma ponte, o outro lado se vincula
economicamente.
E a China se vinculou toda assim, ela tá
toda ah, como é que eu vou dizer? Ela tá
toda facilitada.
>> Como
>> malhavi? Malha ferroviária gigante.
Aí eles estão andando com trens
elétricos super rápidos,
abandonando carbono por todo lado,
criando viadutos e pontes e túneis,
conectando os países ao redor,
estabelecendo ah rotas em outros países
também. Então, quando tu estabelece
rotas em outros países com os portos, tu
amplia tua área econômica.
é inevitável, mas ampliar área econômica
não é só ampliar área econômica. Tu
reduz o custo da produção.
Então eles estão fazendo isso há muito
tempo. E se vocês olharem, por exemplo,
dentro dos Estados Unidos, eles estão
com
sucateamento da infraestrutura deles,
porque eles estão investindo em guerra,
pessoal. Vocês botem lá sucateamento das
estradas e das pontes da infraestrutura
americana. Isso se traduz como o quê?
Aumento de custo. É inevitável.
Aumenta o custo.
Então vocês olhem, as pessoas nos
Estados Unidos estão trabalhando muito
tempo, trabalham muito
e elas não estão protegidas por leis
sociais também. Elas estão uma situação
bem difícil. Agora, com o aumento do
custo de produção,
eu não sei como é que eles raciocinaram,
mas quando tu faz uma sobretaxa,
especialmente da forma como os
americanos fizeram, que é uma é
sobretaxar todo mundo,
quando tu sobretaxa, por exemplo, o
Brasil e não sobretaxa mais ninguém, tu
prejudica o Brasil, porque aí tu compra
dos outros, mas quando sobretaxa os
outros,
aí fica tudo empatado.
Então, como os americanos precisam
daqueles produtos, eles vão comprar
sobretachado. Quando eles compram
sobretachado, aumenta o custo interno.
Aí o custo de vida vai subir, é certo? E
o custo de produção também. Aí se o
custo de produção aumenta, como é que
eles vão exportar?
Entende? Essa é uma pergunta que todo
mundo se faz, ninguém entendeu ainda
assim.
E quando trata mal os estrangeiros, as
pessoas não viajam. Então, tá acabando,
se reduziu muito o turismo também paraos
Estados Unidos. Todo mundo se sente
inseguro. Aí vem vem relatos assim. Aí
tinha um empresário brasileiro que foi a
Disney com dois filhos. Ele ficou 8
horas retido,
não sei bem por, até ser liberado. Aí
aquilo ninguém mais quer viajar.
Então viaja lá, eles estão reavaliando,
eu acho que é 100.000
visas que já foram concedidos,
vistos de entrada, eles estão
reavaliendo tudo. Aí tu tem que ter o
visto de entrada, tu chegar lá e dizer:
"Ah, não, isso aqui não, não tá mais
valendo
assim". E então
nós estamos vivendo esse tipo de
situação assim, né? Então tem uma
mudança muito grande, né?
>> Eu não sei o que que os diplomatas estão
pensando disso, o que que o Itamarati
pensa disso, né? Mas é um é uma questão
assim que não é uma questão desse
governo, é uma questão de Itamarati, né?
Que afinal vai governo, vem governo, tem
o Itamarati
e tem os diplomatas.
Mas talvez seja o segundo ponto que eu
tô falando da área. E agora seja isso,
>> é o que as pessoas dizem.
Mas eu vejo assim o não tem uma posição
da Ásia se agora é nosso tempo, nós
vamos acabar com eles, agora nós vamos
invadir, nós vamos fazer uma guerra, nós
vamos que liquidar com eles, vamos ter
que se render. Não tem essa posição. E
aí vocês vão ver comentaristas que
dizem: "A Ásia trabalha assim", que é
uma forma muito budista de ser pessoal.
Aí tu vai melhorando, tu vai melhorando
e tu vai te movendo e tu não cria
inimigo e tu vai te movendo e vai
andando e fazendo alianças e vai
andando.
Aí vem essas análises.
Antes da expansão ocidental, os maiores
países do mundo eram a China e a Índia.
E agora provavelmente eles vão voltar a
ser.
Aí quando tu vê, por exemplo, foi o o
mod aos Estados Unidos, encontrou o
Trump, fizeram uma aliança,
aí o mod volta pra Índia, aí vem uma
sobretaxa 50%,
ameaçando subir para 100%.
Aí o mod na mesma semana ele foi a
Pequim, encontrou o Xiping. Eles fizeram
uma aliança.
Aí se a China se junta com a Índia,
pessoal, se dá as mãos,
eles vão andando.
Então eu acho que como eu vejo eles se
movendo calmos, sem inimizade,
né? querendo, por exemplo, vocês não vem
o Japão acusando os Estados Unidos, não
vem também a China batendo boca e
ameaçando e mandando navio para lugar
nenhum. Você não estão fazendo nada
disso. Vocês não vem a Coreia dizendo
que os Estados Unidos traíram eles, que
depois de anos de convivência e
subserviência
eles foram traídos. Eles não dizem nada
disso. Eles vão se movendo com calma,
sem gerar inimigos. É como, por exemplo,
a gente trata uma pessoa perturbada.
Tu não luta contra a pessoa, tu acalma,
cria um ambiente de proteção para que o
dano se reduza e deixa aquilo e tenta
acalmar o outro, vai acalmando, tenta
acalmar.
É como eles estão contendo, mas nós
estamos dentro da região de perturbação.
Então para nós, a gente vê só as coisas
explodindo e as comunicações vêm dentro
desse âmbito. A gente não vê, eu não sei
o Itamarati como é. Pô, marati deve
receber tudo de todo lado, né?
Sim, porque tem os diplomatas em todo
lado olhando tudo, né?
Mas eu vejo um risco pro Brasil. Só que
como o Trump tá agindo desse modo, ele
não consegue juntar um aliado porque ele
pega o aliado e mata o olhado.
>> Aquilo.
Então nós estamos vivendo isso, né? Mas
o dharma
sobrevive, né? Eu não sei a nossa
cozinha como é que se sobrevive ou não
sobrevive. Seria isso?
O Luiz Paulo tá esperando lá. Pode
falar, por favor. Primeiro agradeçado
>> prazer, porque não só na geopolítica nós
estamos falando, eu gostaria de comentar
porque tá vendo vários encontros.
>> Uhum.
>> Existe um poder que não falado aqui na
geopolítica que eu queria perguntar.
>> Aham. se é uma narrativa ou não, que é
eh perturbador, emergente, que é o
narcotráfico. Isso é uma narrativa, uma
realidade perigosa dentro que nós
estamos passando, porque o narcotráfico
é a político, não tem política, é um
poder.
>> Isso me preocupa porque eu queria saber
da geopolítica se isso é real, uma
narrativa. Obrigado mais uma vez.
>> Eu acho que é é real. Narcotráfico é
real, ele tá engolindo os países, né?
Então, eu vi recentemente uma análise
assim, como é que os mexicanos lidaram
com isso, né? Eles militarizaram a
relação, colocaram o exército contra o
narcotráfico, começou uma guerra. Vocês
devem ter acompanhado isso em outro
tempo. Aí eles começam a matar
os políticos e vão matando os prefeitos
e vão matando vereador e vão matando
chefe disso, chefe daquilo. E eles se
infiltraram nas próprias forças armadas
assim. Então é tipo um câncer,
a gente tem tecidos, são eles vão sendo
infiltrados,
né? Então aqui no Brasil também as
pessoas associam também uma infiltração
do mundo político em vários mundos. É
assim,
aí se isso é ou não é também não se sabe
muito bem, mas a gente começa a ver
comentários por aqui, por ali, né? É
perfeitamente possível, né? Eu ouvi
também eh citações deles com vários
grupos religiosos também que eles viram
a fachada daquele movimento. Sim.
Mas o narcotráfego,
eu acho que tá ligado
a
ao tempo de degenerescência e falta de
sentido, porque o narcotráfico não te
obriga a te drogar. Ele é ele é ah ele é
uma decorrência disso, né?
Então, por exemplo, eu posso pensar,
não, o problema é a indústria
farmacêutica em geral, assim, né, que
eles são riquíssimos,
mas a indústria farmacêutica tá
atendendo e tá estimulando, num certo
sentido, um tipo de cliente crônico, né?
Então, mas esse é um negócio deles, né?
O negócio deles. Mas se nós cultivarmos
a nossa saúde, a gente não vai tomar
remédio nenhum, pessoal. Então, eh, eu
acho que se a gente tiver estimulando a
saúde, tiver estimulando um tecido
social saudável, uma terra pura nesse
sentido, nós vamos baixar muito o
consumo de
fármacos. Do mesmo modo, eu considero
que essas drogas todas elas estão
ligadas a um tipo de doença, tipo de
desequilíbrio que as pessoas vão
vivendo, que tá ligado a um processo do
ambiente assim, assim como
>> isso é um desbalanço disso. Aí nós
terminamos assim, né? E assim, vamos
pegar uma coisa média, o açúcar também,
né? Aí um tipo de alimento, alguma
coisa. as pessoas vão olhar desse modo,
né? Tem muitas pessoas que ressuscitam
desse modo. Então, a gente tem um tipo
de desbalanço e a gente tem uma procura
de um tipo de alimento também.
Eu acho que todas as comidas rápidas,
todas as comidas processadas, elas
também têm uma ligação desse tipo, né?
Se vocês olharem na Euroveda, vocês vão
ver, tem comida rajásica,
tem comida
tamásica e comida sática.
Se tu tem uma compleção
eh tamásica, tu vai comer a comida
tamásica. Se tu tiver na tua mente um
ambiente rajásico, que é um ambiente
trepidante, tu vai comer pizza,
alguma coisa forte, intensa. Se tu tiver
um um ambiente mais calmo, tu vai comer
comida sátívica naturalmente.
Então, eu considero que as drogas estão
incluídas nesse processo. Assim, né? Eu
acho que a, por exemplo, a
a drogadição é a base do narcotráfico,
né? Mas a base da drogadição é alguma
outra coisa.
Se vocês olharem, foi muito difícil eles
eliminarem o ópio da China, né? Aquela
guerra do ópio, aquilo a gente tem que
olhar aquilo, pessoal, assim, porque é
como se carmicamente o ocidente também
tivesse pagando agora alguma coisa, né?
Porque eles forçaram os chineses a se
drogar e o e a China desabou.
Mas eles eliminaram isso. Eliminaram de
um jeito,
de um jeito que eu não recomendo, né?
Vocês eles eliminaram matando,
mas tá certo que foi um tempo em que
tinha muitas mortes por todos os lados,
né? Foi um tempo horrível. Foi tempo das
invasões japonesas, da invasão japonesa
a China e a destruição de Nanquim, né?
Aquilo foi muito horrível.
Os japoneses não estavam respeitando nem
as regiões diplomáticas, né?
Aí os diplomatas pediram que no mínimo
as embaixadas fossem protegidas, né?
Pode matar tudo o rast, mas deixa aqui.
E aquilo não foi fácil, porque eles
chegaram pelo Rio, entraram na cidade,
começaram a matar todo mundo.
E as as forças de segurança chinesas
foram embora. Elas saíram porque elas
não tinham como se proteger e assim o
exército chinês mais ou menos se
preservou, né? Mas a luta contra japonês
foi alguma coisa muito horrível que eu
também não tenho que me meter nisso, né?
Falar, mas é tem vários episódios
extraordinários assim.
Aí tem ascensão do Maltetung,
apoiado pelos russos que tomaram a
manchúria dos japoneses. E ali eles
acolheram o exército comunista do as
forças do Maltatung e daquele hub eles
se espalharam pela China inteira, né? E
a força deles foi pelo fato de que eles
faziam a reforma agrária.
Então onde eles iam entrando, eles
dividiam a terra.
Aí as pessoas queriam a terra, se
juntaram com os comunistas, tão eram
quanto o país.
E aí, nesse tempo as forças que eram
apoiadas pelos Estados Unidos, que eram
as forças do
Shankai Cheek, elas se refugiaram em
Taiwan. Então, por isso que até hoje
isso é é uma questão que não tá
resolvida, como se a revolu a luta
interna
completado, porque os chineses eles
recuperaram, vou dizer, o governo
assumiu o país, exceto um pedacinho que
era que é Taiwan, aonde tá ainda o
exército antigo que combateu, né?
Então tem esse enrosco. Por isso que os
países todos, incluindo o Brasil,
consideram que a China, incluindo o
Taiwan, é o único país
que tá ainda num processo de
resolução,
não se inclusive os Estados Unidos,
Estados Unidos também considera isso,
né? Mas houve o tempo que Taiwan tinha o
assento da ONU
e a China não tinha.
E aí houve a partir do Nixon, iso foi
Nixon, teve lá o Kissinger,
ele costurou isso e os chineses tomaram
assento na ONU e o assento no conselho
de segurança e Tawan saiu.
Eu lembro disso quando isso aconteceu,
né?
Não quero
um tempão na frente.
>> Comida tá esfriando, professor. Não sei.
Vocês estão num papo solto aqui. Eu já
tinha até desistido, mas a minha
pergunta
eh assim, eu tive um contato maior com
budismo na Tailândia, que é teravada e e
muitas coisas maravilhosas. Eu de fato,
de verdade agradeço muitíssimo, mas eu
me impressionou muito que lá é muito
machista, né? Eu vi eu vi assim a
cultura em geral, né? Mas as mulheres
fazendo doações para criar um mérito,
para reencarnar como homens. Uhum.
>> E aqui alguém também mencionou de alguma
guerra que as mulheres lutaram, que elas
matavam, mas não com raiva. E toda essa
situação, né, assim, querendo ou não, é
coordenada por homens. Você, né,
mencionou também. Aí eu queria saber
tanto a sua visão quanto do budismo em
geral, se é que existe budismo em geral
sobre se tem, né, porque outras
linhagens nativas e falam, né, de uma
ascensão da energia feminina, não
necessariamente de mulheres, mas de uma,
né, uma visão mais feminina.
Eh, se tem a ver isso com essa com uma
possível um possível otimismo assim de
mudança social.
>> Eu acho que sim, eu acho que é que na
visão eu prefiro entender assim, vou
dizer como é que eu prefiro entender,
né? Porque afinal que mostrar as
realidades como que é, né? Eu prefiro
entender que a palavra mulher é
reservada para um tipo de função e não
para um ser.
Então, as mulheres rezam para nascerem
como homens,
liberadas daquela função, porque quando
elas nascem como mulher, o papel delas
tá bem claro.
Mas, por exemplo, se vocês vão olhar os
ensinamentos, não tem distinção.
Aí tem vários exemplos. Eu eu considero
um dos exemplos mais extraordinários o
budismo tibetano mesmo com o guru pochê,
porque guru pochê deu os ensinamentos
paraal
ele ainda falava mal do rei.
Então por que que ele vai dar um
ensinamento para para uma mulher?
Ele dá ensinamento para ela e ela é que
vai preservar o ensinamento dele. Não é
nenhum cavaleiro,
ela.
Então é assim. E ela também, ela não
abdicou da eh da biologia dela,
mas ela abdicou do papel de mulher,
porque ela não foi não foi mãe e não foi
esposa e não não viveu numa família.
Então ela ela escapou daquilo que as
pessoas queriam escapar, porque a as
mulheres naquele tempo simplesmente não
tinham dentro daquela estrutura rural,
elas não tinham como se mover de outro
modo né?
Então viagem de São Guel, como outras
também, como Mandarava e outras, elas
escaparam daquela condição.
E é interessante ver que qualquer lugar
que eu passo que tenha, né, um trabalho
espiritual é quase sempre, eu acho que
sempre tem mais mulheres do que homem,
né? Olha, até na sala aqui tem.
>> Essa é uma falha nossa aqui.
Eu acho isso maravilhoso assim. Eu
também não sei por, mas tudo bem.
Mas com o microfone é mais os homens.
Se os homens aqui com o microfone de um
lado pro outro. Assim,
>> Lama, eh, dentro desse nosso diálogo
é inevitável as reflexões muito
objetivas né?
E eu percebi nessa nossa conversa sobre
a questão de narcotráfico, por exemplo,
que as coisas elas estão de uma certa
forma, de uma certa forma, não, de uma
forma total encadeadas
e que não existe um macro lá sem um
micro aqui. Então isso é muito
interessante perceber a gradação
em que cada um de nós esteja ou não
comprometido com esse culto aos estados
alterados de consciência. Por que isso?
Eh, aqui mesmo na nossa comunidade em
Alto Paraíso e até com uma parte da
sanga, a gente tem se proposto algumas
relações com crianças, com adolescentes
e tudo por quê?
Porque a gente percebe um nível de
fragmentação psíquica via adulteração da
consciência.
Então isso é muito interessante porque
existem correntes, eu tenho amigos muito
próximos que se colocam de forma muito
intimista com relação a drogas, com
relação ao convívio familiar e social
íntimo, com pessoas, inclusive
adolescentes, em que isso é entra dentro
de um espectro assim mais ou menos
normal. Eu me sinto à vontade de falar
sobre isso porque eh caminho e não é de
escritório,
é de multivisões psicodélicas. e a
conclusão de que a fragmentação psíquica
não é exatamente um caminho de coesão,
de foco e que possa produzir realmente
algo objetivo, amoroso, compassivo e
solidário. É a visão que eu tenho e
tenho procurado me irmanar com esse tipo
de visão. Claro que eu encontro
oposições ideológicas, inclusive, porque
ou não é a favor da liberação, não, não
sou, eu trabalho em outra direção. E
esses posicionamentos, eles geram
fricções. Às vezes, olha, arreaça, não,
enfim, não tem problema, faz parte. Mas
é interessantíssimo essa relação do
macro e do micro, porque vê o
narcotráfico como algo que é consequente
da drogadição, sim, que estão
interligados, sim, mas também olhar como
se tivesse assistindo um safari paraa
África, não. Nós estamos dentro dele,
participativamente dentro dele, né? Cada
um, a consciência é muito elástica. Não,
eu não vou me carpar,
né, todos os dias. Eu não vou dar teco
todos os dias, mas também tem também um
é como aquele bolo começou o pedacinho.
Então
>> eu não comi ainda, tô guardando.
>> Pois é,
desculpa, L, mas é é porque realmente
ficou emergente essa abordagem, porque
senão fica uma coisa assim muito eh
periférica e ela é eu eu percebo que ela
é uma coisa de corresponsabilidade.
Todos nós estamos no mesmo barco.
>> Eu eu diria assim, antes da gente ir pro
almoço, eu só encerraria do seguinte
modo.
É assim, nós budistas fazendo o que nós
estamos fazendo, eu acho que a gente já
tá contribuindo para ultrapassar a
drogadição,
n? Porque na medida em que a gente a
gente toma refúgio no Buda, d na
sangida,
uma simplicidade,
um olho que vê. A gente não busca
amortecimento, uma mente que fica presa
numa direção ou em outra. Nós estamos
buscando uma mente lúcida. É uma coisa
assim simples. Então não é que a gente
seja contra isso ou contra aquilo,
porque se a gente for contra, a gente
não consegue nem acolher. Nós não
estamos julgando, mas eh a gente acha
melhor que as pessoas, em vez de fixarem
estados mentais meditativos ou estados
mentais eh psicodélicos, a pessoa tenha
um refúgio na lucidez e não nos estados
psicodélicos ou ou os estados
perturbados, que são os próprios estados
meditativos onde nós vamos gerando
apego. Assim, o Buda, ele fica
descrevendo isso, né?
E também eu vou lembrar
Jol contra o Rochet que milagrosamente
era o dono desse mala aqui. Incrível.
Era mala pessoal dele. Ele faleceu
depois. Isso tem uma história que
terminou comigo,
mas foi o primeiro mestre que eu fiz
refúgio.
Então, John Gol contra o Rebochet, ele
eh frente a uma pergunta dessas, ele
diz: "Olha, nós já temos muita
perturbação na mente, a gente não
precisa outros estados perturbados." Eu
achei aquilo super lúcido.
Então tã.
Eu, por mim posso seguir aqui, mas a Inê
tá aqui atrapalhando tudo.
A culpa é da Inê. Assim, a gente podia
não almoçar hoje, só jantar, entende?
Depois você aquece a janta e pronto.
Então que os méritos desse encontro se
expandam e toquem a todos. Que o Mestre
Universal da Paz e da Compaixão, Sua
Santidade da Lailama, juntamente com
todos os mestres de todas as tradições
que veiculam essa mensagem, tenham longa
vida. Que todos estejam a salvo de gerar
pensamentos negativos,
obstáculo mais destrutivo,
que esses pensamentos nunca surgem em
nossa mente e que todos os seres também
estejam livres de pensamentos negativos
ao longo de minhas muitas vidas e até
este momento, todas as virtudes que t
alcançado, inclusive os méritos gerados
por esta prática e todas as que vier a
conseguir ir. Ofereço para o bem-estar
dos seres sencientes.
Possam a doença, guerra, fome e
sofrimento diminuir para todos os seres,
enquanto sua sabedoria e compaixão
aumentam nesta em vidas futuras. possa
eu claramente perceber todas as
experiências como sendo tão
insubstanciais quanto o tecido do sonho
durante a noite e imediatamente
despertar para perceber a manifestação
de sabedoria pura
de cada fenômeno. possa eu rapidamente
alcançar iluminação para trabalhar sem
cessar pela liberação de todos os seres
budas e bodissátuas em conjunto, seja
qual for a sua motivação, sua ação
benéfica e preces auspiciosas,
seja qual for a sua onisciência,
realizações e poderes benévolos. E seja
qual for a sua imensa sabedoria,
eu que igualmente venho para beneficiar
os seres, rogo para que possa alcançar
as mesmas qualidades. Neste exato
momento, possam nem mesmo os nomes
doença, fome, guerra e sofrimento ser
ouvidos pelas pessoas e nações da terra,
mas possam sim sua conduta moral,
mérito, riqueza e prosperidade crescer.
bema-aventurança e bem-estar sempre
surgir para ela.
[Música]
Sé.
Então, é, o retiro foi meio curto, né?
Eu acho. Faltou, faltou um trechão que
eu tinha que ter falado aqui, pessoal.
>> Eu acho,
>> eu acho. Só não sei se vai dar, mas eu
acho também.
Já começa essa pressão. Vocês estão
vendo isso aí? Como é? possível
>> aqui em Alparaíso, né?
>> Olha, eh, pensando bem, a distância é a
mesma, né? Eu não quero aqui forçar as
coisas né?
>> Isso aqui seria o CB Centro-Oeste.
>> Ai, bonito isso, né? Ficou bonito assim,
né?
Lama tem a não morte.
Quero que ela seja,
obrigado, Nia, obrigada. Se bem que eu
tenho pelo menos uma pessoa aqui.
>> A gente vai pode continuar
a gente vai pegar na massagem
quear quem é aquele centro.
>> Eu acho que o Centro tá super bem assim,
né? Tive em Goiânia, eu fiquei tão feliz
lá de ver que tá andando super bem, né?
>> E Quindinho aquele quindinha eu fiquei
olhando também que nem o bolo. Fiquei
olhando.
Mas a pamonha, aquela pamonha goiana
super boa assim, ela é melhor que pão,
pessoal. Eu acho como
>> sem glúten. Au, eu tenho esse.
>> Eu eu vi um pão maravilhoso lá assim e
aqui, né? Pão todo decorado.
Com certeza.
>> Mas não é pamonha.
Tô indo bem aí. Tô indo bem. Piqui, né?
Piqu vem na
>> É o piqui faltou, né? Vocês tinham
prometido, mas faltou aquilo.
Prometido.
>> É, né? Pois é. Mas olha, eu tô eu tô com
um problema porque é como aqui eu só
consegui comer um pouquinho de tudo que
chegou.
Aham. Mas eu acho que ainda tinha alguma
coisa para dizer assim,
>> uma despedida.
[Risadas]
Eu é assim, nosso tempo tá super curto,
né? Mas eu tenho observado a Ana assim
há bastante tempo lá de Goiânia, né?
Eh,
eu queria
dizer para vocês terem cuidado com ela,
assim, vocês cuidem bem dela, porque ela
é preciosa assim, sabe? Eu acho que a
Ana, por exemplo, na na minha visão, não
sei se ela aceita isso, né? Mas eu acho
que ela poderia ser ela tomar esse peso
que é operar como uma tutora, né? poder
ajudar as sangas desse modo assim, né?
>> É,
eu acho que vou dar um tempo para ela
pensar, porque isso é uma coisa super
grave.
Eu acho que a a Ana gosta de coisa
pesada assim, né? E e ela tem essa
história de vida que ela sabe fazer
muito bem isso.
>> Ah, então eu vou ganhar o quê, então?
Como é que tá?
>> Obrigado, viu? Obrigado.
Então,
então já já se despediu, né?
Então agora
>> tá. Catar.
>> Tchau, pessoal. Beijo aí.
A gente se vê.
>> Tchau, Lama. Obrigada.
Obrigada.
>> Tchau. Lama.
>> Beijo. Lama. Obrigada.
Gratidão. Abraço. Tchau.